this is Jocko podcast number 367 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening I don't like
going to the doctor okay just FYI I
don't like hospitals
actually
I always think that things are they're
just going to heal up right the body's
just going to Wolverine and just heal up
and
they do most of the time occasionally
they don't
one time I woke up in the morning I
couldn't move my right arm but didn't
move which is not a good feeling
I was like okay well it'll get better it
didn't uh I had to go to the doctor
went to the doctor got you know neck
surgery
so unless something is really bad
I'm not going to the doctor
I don't know if that's left over from
basic SEAL training where they you're
avoiding medical at all costs because
you don't want to get rolled or anything
but it stuck with me don't like the
doctor a little while after I had neck
surgery
I would start to randomly getting dizzy
like
like dizzy like I just spun around in
circles sometimes I would get really
dizzy sometimes I would be trying to
walk
and I would be bouncing into walls so
I'm talking legitimately busy I was
nauseous
a lot
almost almost like a continual almost
all the time nauseous
and
man sometimes Jiu Jitsu I would be doing
Jiu Jitsu and I'd like roll or spin or
something like that and it would just be
the G the whole gym would just start
spinning
sometimes I would roll over in bed at
night and the room would start spinning
it was
then you know you're feeling sick
and I kind of learned to avoid some
things you know in Jiu Jitsu I try not
to go inverted and stuff like this and
in bed I learned to roll like if I
wanted to roll over in bed or even to
roll to get out of bed I would learn to
do it very very slowly and avoid head
movement and I thought it would go away
you know I'm waiting for go to wag
waiting for Wolverine blood to flow and
for the problem to stop and it didn't
stop so again went to the hospital went
to the doctor and they did all kinds of
tests on the MRI tests and blood tests
and they ear nose and throat spine they
just did they looked at everything and
they didn't have an answer for me
and so I'm just dealing with it just BTF
and just dealing with it
and it definitely sucked
um
and then like so fast forward a year or
something like that
I'm actually starting my retirement
processing and I'm starting my
retirement physical you got to get a
physical before you retire and I'm
talking to the doc for the West Coast
seals and what's cool about this
particular dock is he was a seal himself
who had gone to the military medical
school and become a doctor so you know
we knew each other
and he's get you know we're hanging out
and then he's giving me sort of the
standard retirement physical questions
about my health and I'm giving him the
standard retirement answers which is
fine yep fine yep that's fine and you
know we're just kind of shooting
shooting the breeze a little bit he goes
there's anything else you know did I
miss anything
and I said well you know
no one's been able to help me but I'll
throw it out there I said yeah man for
the last like year year and a half
I've randomly gotten just really dizzy
sometimes and sometimes it lasts for a
long time and it kind of never goes away
I'm always in like a constant state of
that
and he's like kind of tilt his head a
little bit looked at me and kind of
thumbing through my record you seeing
now that he's looking at he's seen a
bunch of tests that I've been through
and everything like this
and he says you know what I think I
might know what this might be
and he literally like turns to his
computer and this is 2010 but
or maybe it was 2009 something like that
because I I retired in 2010 but it was
some it was like around that time but he
turns his computer and he Googles some
stuff
and he's like here here look at this
and he says benign positional vertigo
he goes we got to do these little
exercises
and uh I'm like
okay I mean I don't know what he's
talking about right benign positional
vertigo I don't know what this means
and then he like says okay lay down put
your head over here turn it backwards
turn over sit back up again and he goes
does like three or four times does these
exercises and then like says all right
stand up
and he looks at me and he goes how's
that
and I'm like
doing a self-assessment and I'm like
dude it's gone I'm good like literally
in two minutes more than a year of
dizziness and constant tests and exams
and this thing is gone in two minutes
that sealed dock
gave me uh my balance back and it was
pretty freaking awesome and this
particular doc has helped
countless other seals overcome countless
health challenges of all kinds his name
is Kirk parsley and
it's an honor to have him with us here
today to talk about what he learned uh
in his life in the teams and taking care
of Team guys so doc thanks for coming by
man hey man thanks for having me do you
remember that I mean I remember eight
million people so I remember very
clearly
yeah yeah but you you you weren't like
sure about it when you said it to me you
were sort of like look at you kind of it
was like it seemed as if you had heard a
rumor about something that it could have
been and you kind of like halfway
remembered it right and then you I think
I could I could remember I could
remember the name of the test that you
do to test people for that right
um and I was like and I'm blanking on
now it's like Pikes Hall something or
like this and uh I was like hmm and you
look for the nystagmus right the shaking
of the eyes and it's something you do to
like hospital patients and uh and so I
knewed that part and I was like I know
so there's a little Stone in one of your
semicircular canals and it's blocking
that and so the fluid's not flowing and
it's the same as seasickness or
something right at that point and so uh
I remember
uh I remember well there's there's a way
to tilt there's a way to tilt this out
and I couldn't remember if there's like
a certain pattern because you have three
canals and they're all at different
angles so that's why you like turn your
head at all these different angles so
many times
I was like oh no I know there's
something to like do this and uh you
know medicine's full of
um we'll call eponyms like you know the
shit's just named after people uh right
so what is Epley maneuver it's not
descriptive at all so I don't know what
the hell that means somebody's name is
maneuver there right and I'm like
there's some kind of thing and so that's
what I Googled like uh you know clearing
uh yeah and and so it's just like
clearing the stones that are in the
semicircular canal and I think I'm
looking for that video and I'm like oh
here's how we do it so
I remember like leaning the table back
down and going right uh because we like
we knew each other we didn't know each
other super well at that point uh yeah
but you had your [__]
BTF uh you know uh reputation I don't
know if I ever told you did you ever
hear about the bracelets
and no at our clinic right so we at the
Rehab Clinic
you know Jason trained all these guys
and uh
you know and
it's hard to bounce back from surgeries
a lot of time right and people aren't
all that motivated because they're just
they're used to like this performance
I'm supposed to be up here and like
they're barely like they're barely
performing like a grade school kid or
something
um and so there's always a motivation
component and uh so he had these tests
for people to like you know try to try
to get to this level try to get to that
level try to and it's like these
Progressive steps and so and then there
was some sort of reward involved in it
and that's that's how we ended up in
June Sears Tower with Elliot and all
that stuff like that was part of the
reward kind of pathway and uh one thing
we so this is heretic and I hope your
audience doesn't hate me for saying this
but um the wwjd what would Jesus do
bracelets We heard like 100 of those and
we gave them they were what would y'all
could do
and we had like this running list on the
wall of like uh
Chuck Norris kind of thing
my contribution was uh
Jocko sleeps with the pillow under his
gun
so anyways yeah so uh you know you had a
reputation and I knew you were and uh
and I remember doing all that and going
I hope this works
I don't know I'm done and uh yeah and
and uh I and then we you know as we got
to know each other more over the years I
know you you had to do that do you still
have to do it I probably have to do it
once a year oh and it but it's it's just
such a non-factor now I go oh there it
is I'm a little dizzy boom but I just do
it and yeah man it's
I was like that for a year and a half
and it was gnarly gnarly I remember I
was doing I was training a guy for a
fight an MMA fight
and uh
he was like ground and pound like we had
gloves on like we're going at it and all
of a sudden like I did something where I
did a quick head movement and all of a
sudden I got super D like like more even
more dizzy than normal
and I'm standing there I'm like laying
on my back and he's in my guard he's
punching me in the head
and I I look at the clock and the clock
there's like
this was this was uh Thomas remember
Thomas yeah I mean he's freaking polish
Warrior yeah and he's punching me in the
head and um there's like 20 seconds left
and I'm just like please let this stop
and I I got up and walked and I I like
was doing a drunk walk out you know all
unstable and he he was kind of like
looking at me as if he had hit me too
hard or something is just like no I'm
leaving now
uh that and when the good thing you have
thick skull
from that guy for sure he's a beast yeah
I had uh actually that's when that's
when Jan the the
champ yeah not currently but hopefully
coming back for it uh just part of that
Maniac dude that's not a good way to be
healthy you know uh yeah and then I had
the I don't know if you remember this I
I go
I was training jiu jitsu
uh I didn't I did a oh no Dean did a a
bicep Slice on me and like my bicep like
popped and moved and I was like God you
got a partial tear I remember and he and
so I go in I see Jason I see Doc yeah
and they're like yup hey we can get you
scheduled for surgery right now you know
like and I go cool like sign me up let's
rock and roll and then they go okay yep
we got you signed up your your surgery
is going to be in four weeks or
something like this three weeks or
something like this and they go come in
on this day for your pre-surgery check I
go cool and so I go in I'm like Jason
yeah I'm here for my priest Jack and he
goes he starts looking at me all weird
and stuff like I'm not normal yeah and
he's like hey Doc can you come ahead and
they come and look at me and they're
like
you're healed
uh and I was like yes yeah all right
backs I see I I remember I remember that
like they're they're still being like
some sort of defect in that and uh
and we I remember we told her like
well it still might rip right with what
you do because like if you're resisting
an arm bar or something like you know
you are doing pull-ups whatever maybe it
might still rip and uh and you're like
what happens if it rips or like well
then you do this surgery like
same surgery pretty much like well I'll
see if it rips
you just went on about your life and I
guess it never happened never I was
gonna ask you about that now now Echo
over here he's had one on each arm he's
done that really needed that surgery
twice did I call you when you when that
happened to me was I like hey what's up
yeah so remember uh that's funny you
don't remember because I was I'm glad
you're here to kind of confirm that
because I didn't believe I was like
right it wasn't ripped yeah you can't
it's not just gonna heal like that like
it was a rip like the doc made a mistake
or whatever no you're like no no I'm
like Wolverine Wolverine I was like all
right that sounds good that does sound
cool but right it didn't rip or whatever
it was like whatever it was like an
argument
now I do accept it yeah thanks for
confirming all right enough about that
uh let's get into you let's start at the
beginning so where where where were you
born where where were you born where'd
you grow up uh I was born in sort of a
sub area of Houston spring Spring Texas
or Spring Branch actually so Spring
Branch Hospital in Houston outside of
Houston and then is that where you spent
your your youth yeah uh pretty much so
by today's standards definitely because
Katie where I spent like the second
second half of my childhood was in Katy
um
that was like 45 minutes outside of
Houston then and now it's just like part
of Houston like with all the sprawl like
you you literally drove through like cow
pastures and rice fields for 45 minutes
and then there was this one road and he
took that one road for like three or
four miles and then you ran into the
neighborhoods of Katy
and uh last time I went there
there's no break from downtown Houston
to that's like all concrete just don't
go like shopping
I couldn't even find the house I grew up
in
you think it's still there or no it's
still there okay but like all the
landmarks I knew to look for and they've
renamed some streets and stuff and so
you know when you get off the freeway
now there's streets immediately well
there was nothing like I said for three
or four miles or just pastures where we
rode our motorcycles and played football
and whatever uh even went hunting and
like and that was all
you know on whatever farmland and and
untouched Thicket and it was just like
buildings and shopping centers and
streets and I'm like I like I don't
really know how far down to go and I was
looking for the main kind of street that
went through my neighborhood
and uh I think they've renamed that
street and because it they've connected
it and it's much longer now and and so I
couldn't figure out where to turn left
to like go into the neighborhoods so
small town in Texas yeah how come you
don't have a Texas accent I do want to
get really tired it's got It's kind of
coming back more I deliberately got rid
of it how come
um
just to avoid being chastised for you
know like being in the military you know
people
screw with you about because I listen to
country music and I drove a truck and
you know like a redneck you know uh you
know uh Chris my you know like my the
good friend of mine from the still teams
he you know he's from essentially
Detroit right and
he don't think damn Texan go get me some
chiliary like and everybody just Road me
all the time so I didn't have a super
thick accent but you know I I purposely
got rid of it now that I'm back in Texas
and everybody talks like I used to talk
and it's coming back it comes back and
uh and then if I get really tired uh I
think my like that's my real like I
think it's a it's an it's an unconscious
effort now to not
do that and not I've let the
colloquialisms come back like now I'm
fixing to do something like I wouldn't
do that and I say y'all and say you guys
and I've always thought that was more
appropriate because like that's a
contraction for you all and guys this is
a gender word so it doesn't make any
sense called a bunch of girls hey you
guys there you all right uh so yeah it
it kind of It kind of comes and goes
what'd you what'd your parents do
uh
well my father split that was what he
did so like about I was like six weeks
old or something
um
and so I actually met him at my wedding
I think one is 25. uh so what'd your
mama do my mom uh so the so the first
half of my childhood
um
uh when we were
Poor trailer park trash you know um and
uh but my mom my mom actually had to
drop out of high school to raise her
younger sisters because her parents ran
off you know and uh so my mom had us
when we were super young like me and my
sister she had like 18 19 years old and
uh so
she you know she got married right out
of high school essentially uh and so she
went to she's going to college and
working as like a cocktail waitress or
something like when I was young and then
when she remarried just when we moved to
Katie and uh
she married a who's a cop at the time
and he he
went on to do other things
um but she started working with Delta
Airlines and was like a reservationist
then became a flight attendant
and then she retired from that and
worked for Southwest as a flight
attendant for a while and now she was in
her 70s and she just retired like a
couple of years ago from Southwest she
was getting after she's a hard she's a
hard like Irish redhead like feisty wiry
strappy strong woman you know uh and so
uh
yeah and and uh cheetah she divorced
that that stuff other when I was like
16. he's a super super abusive
to everybody but especially me um and so
um so how did you react to that
um
was a big insult to me because I was the
man of the house until that right so I
was like Hey I was up I was up until
like eight years old she got married
when I was like eight or nine and I grew
up with all women so it's my mom her mom
her sisters
and my sister and
at five years old they'd be like Kirk I
think I heard something good luck right
so okay get my Red Rider BB gun and like
go and look and look in the living room
see if anybody's there uh literally sent
me out in the front yard to kill water
moccasin with a BB gun and thank God
like like a man was driving by and saw
this [__] show about to happen it's like
let me go save this little boy so he
came out like you know and I taught me
how to you know I stepped on the snake's
head and cut its head off with his
health and all that and whatever so
um so I was really Blown Away by the
fact that some other dude showed up some
dudes kinda
like hurt my mother hurt my sister right
and so I'd always like try to get
involved and then he'd turn on me and so
that was my strategy for a while but
he's an evil
yeah and so he he figured out well it's
worse if I don't turn on Kirk right just
let me keep trying to interject and just
ignore me and keep hurting my mom or
whatever so
um
so I grew up very [__] angry very
angry and uh I wanted to kill him and I
fully planned on it
and uh you know my mom
I asked my mom for a weight set for
Christmas when I was eight
uh
Pumping Iron had come out I'd seen
Arnold [__] I was like yeah I'm gonna
get over the muscles I'm gonna crush and
uh and I knew my dad was a big dude and
kind of a badass and and they knew each
other
uh I grew up kind of in the same town
and uh
so I think I was a threat to him right I
was my potential father and so his
biggest fear was that I was gonna go to
be
better than him bigger better faster
stronger whatever and all of his fears
came true but
uh at 16 I had
uh so did you get the weight set at
eight I got the weight set at 8. he came
into me he came into my room he's like I
heard you want to wait sit you wouldn't
wait to where he would be one of those
[__]
I'm sorry excuse me are you telling me
well bodybuilders are all gay and that's
why they like to shave their bodies and
bury around other men and all this other
stuff and I'm like
I don't think so whatever so with the
weight so I didn't know what to do with
him I got like the little bar with the
concrete weights oh yeah and I was
grounded my whole life the whole time I
was with him right so if I got a battery
report card I got grounded to the next
report card and then grounded to the
next ground and then the last report
card of the year I was grounded six
weeks into the summer because that's
when another report card so I'd had like
eight weeks of Summer like that was the
only time I had any kind of social life
so I sat in my room a lot got grounded
in my room a lot
and I'd sit and like all I knew how to
do was overhead press that's like that's
what you think of as I just sit there
and like a red pressed or in front and
back front back front and then uh and
curl and that's all I did and I just sit
in my room for hours and just lift
weights
um and then
you know every time I tried to take any
kind of martial arts he
did everything could thwart that and uh
so I like I'd get in something and he'd
just make it impossible for me to stick
with it and all that so
um
I I was really really angry and that the
only reason I think I was good at
football is because I was so damn angry
and and now and I was a big fast strong
kid
um and I just I just literally wanted to
hurt everybody I could like it was a way
for me to hurt people and not get in
trouble because like getting in fights
you got you always got in trouble for
the fights or most of the time how old
were you started playing football
um actually I started in kindergarten uh
I played we lived on this island in the
Ship Channel that's where our trailer
was and it was Kemah Texas is the name
of it and it's just now is like a kind
of a ritzy tourist area but it was just
like this little blue-collar crappy
bunch of shrimp boats and stuff
um and so we I lived there
uh literally my sister and I said a year
old and I we walked to school across
these railroad tracks and I remember
walking to football practice walking
home from a football game like me and my
pads her and her cheerleader outfit and
were like walking like probably two
miles like our school going across these
major roads whatever it's like parenting
was a totally different bag back then
right but my mom was like I said she was
surviving she's like going to school at
night and or going to school in the day
working at night uh and then her sisters
were just kids too right like her
sisters were raisins but they're 15 like
was a 15 year old now uh and like
sometimes the 15 year old gets in the
car when the car runs and drives this
around and whatever so it was it was a
pretty sketchy scene
um and then you know in Texas you can
start playing so I played what we call
Dad's Club popcorn around here right
um I played that and then in Texas you
start playing for your school in junior
high okay and I had uh
the head coach of in junior high was a
former Marine
and uh he took a liking to me and so I I
did well in uh Junior High football and
then transferred to
um the really a really good football
team my our high school their two high
schools and and uh Katie the one I went
to is the newer one and it had only been
open a couple years when I started it
but we're going to we had a great
coaching staff uh and uh
and you know in Texas like
these dudes are making big money and
like and they they got recruited out to
Odessa my senior year but um
but really really good coaching in that
and that's what led me into power
lifting is one of my one of my coaches
was a power lifter and he and I uh I'm I
don't know if I was the strongest in
like every lift but I was I was one of
the strongest and everything and I was
the strongest in several of the things
um and so he was he took a liking to me
and he's like I'm gonna teach you how to
lift for real because you're like you're
just doing football lifting and so he
taught me like the below parallel squats
right and I had to do it with a bar
and I had to do 100 perfect reps before
he'd let me put any weight on damn
and it took me like a month he would sit
down next to me and just count watch and
go yep yeah nope I need to turn around
walk away that was it for the day if
that was on the second rep is on the
second rep but it was on the 98th rep
it's the 98th rep and they're like nope
did you did you have the potential of
playing in college
um
I could have played I don't think I
would have I wouldn't have excelled I
just wasn't big enough I mean I was I
was uh I actually grew a couple inches
in the Navy uh so I when when I enlisted
it
17 I was
um 511. I grew like to 6-1 somewhere in
the first couple years I don't know did
you uh how did you hear about the Navy
well and did you and did you know about
the teams yeah so that's a funny story
so
um the recruiter we had a recruiting
office and Katie and uh the recruiter
the marine recruiter was was a boxer and
and my last year of high school I lived
alone where I lived in an apartment with
actually with a guy who owns his gym so
I split an apartment but
and I work I worked at a gym I was like
this the assistant manager of this gym
and uh
and anyway and I would box with this
marine recruiter and you know
Heartbreaker Ridge had already been out
says like force Recon yeah you know and
and I you know and I love like I've
always loved the water like I've always
been like as I was a lifeguard and where
I was like uh doing water sports and
going to the beach whenever we could and
all that stuff
um working on breath holds just because
it was cool in fact like I would go in a
pool and just be so upset that it had to
come up right because I like I'd sit on
the bottom of a pool like I just want to
stay here for like and you know now sort
of I know more the physiology of like
what I was now like settling down my
nervous system honestly and I was
feeling really good in there and um
so uh yes so anyway uh then I started uh
boxing with this marine recruiter and uh
and uh this documentary came out
48 Hours uh it's a news documentary show
like it's like 60 minutes but it's
called 48 hours and they followed a
budge class actually uh
crimens remember crimens yeah so crimens
was like the star of this they're
following a buzz class okay and Nick was
he in the class he was in the class like
he was he was the guy right like he was
the one he was the guy who got all the
camera attention because he was like
this salty old yeah for sure fisherman
from Boston or something right uh
somewhere in New England and uh and they
kept saying this is the toughest
training in the world this is the
toughest and what did I grow up doing
like with this abusive stepfather I
wanted to be the toughest I wanted to be
the biggest badass in the world right
that's what I wanted
um and so I would I I watched that thing
it recorded on VHS and I watched that
thing like 20 times
and then I waited for the Marine
recruiter to be out of town
I went over to the Navy and talked to
him about being a seal what what year in
high school were you
well it was my fourth year but my fourth
year I was only a sophomore by credits
so was that because you just were
failing everything I started I started
failing classes as soon as my mom got
remarried and I got in that um right
like when you have
screaming fighting and
cops over your house all the time it's
like yeah and I'm grounded all the time
at home and he's abusive and I'll just
like hiding from like and it was just I
wasn't gonna be doing homework and that
like my sympathetic nervous system was
ramped up to hell like I'm I'm in fight
or flight kind of all the time being
home uh and so
yeah I
I
whatever I I I was a screwed up I was a
super screwed up kid uh but anyway uh so
Bivens out of town I went and talked to
the Navy recruiter
and he's like I've never put an SEO
before I don't know I'll look into it
and that they just started the delayed
entry program right so that started
literally months before uh I I signed up
so I told my mom what I wanted to do and
she was like all right so she signed off
on it off the payroll yeah and uh yes so
anyway yeah I so from like third grade
through four years of high school
I don't I'd never really legitimately
passed any class unless a teacher like
me and you know then everybody starts
telling you
what a [__] you are and you're afraid
of
people finding out so you're like you
know I don't I don't want to call any
attention to my stupidity so I'm just
like being quiet and like and so nobody
like none of my friends knew that I was
behind in high school like none of my
none of my friends knew that I wasn't
going to graduate I knew I wasn't going
to graduate because I wasn't going to
stick around for two or three more years
to get through High School obviously
um and so when I joined I was just like
at some point I'm going to go get a GED
and then and then I took the ASVAB and
then actually did
decent on that
and uh
yeah so I I joined
I and I didn't tell I still didn't tell
the Marine tradition I was like afraid
he was gonna be so pissed off of me
um and then uh
yeah just like a month we had all these
Street parties you know like vacant
streets you'd go
we could park our cars turn lights on
and have cake parties and whatever
um
and it was always a mix of the high
schools and there's always some friction
because we're rifles you know in sports
and uh it's about a month after I joined
about a month after my Marine career
found out uh that I joined that I think
it was a couple months after I joined
um
I I tried to break up a fight and this
dude swung on me and like graced me
right like I
I that decent enough head movement
together away but he like grazed me and
I was such an angry rage ball and so
arrogant
I was maximally offended to somebody who
tried to just I'm like who the [__] do
you think you are so I try to look at
the guy just bewildered and I guess
there's something in my eyes that made
him realize and he took off running and
so I took off running after him and I
[__] body slammed him down the street
and punch him in one of his buddies
comes I started beating his ass and I
beat up these two guys right and this
one he's curled up in the fetal position
I'm picking him up by his ears and tell
him to fight and he won't not spit in
his face like I was angry nasty dude and
uh anyway and so
I pull up to see my Marine recruiter
right to see the Navy recruiter I pull
up to a recruiting office a few days
later and
uh the marine recruiter comes out and he
said so what's this I hear about you
beating up on my Marines oh like
yeah so anyway so I watched that thing
over and over again wanted to do
toughest training in the world
went and joined I didn't know what a
seal was uh
I I didn't even I didn't know what a
seal was when I was in buds I wanted to
do the toughest training in the world
and yeah I gradually learned more and
more but I still didn't know like when I
don't know if they did it uh when you
went through you were a couple years
after me I think right
um but we they used to take us around
all the different SEAL Teams and then
you had to rank Choice like the team and
you had a rank choice to the east coast
well as also without visiting any of
those
and I remember like when they started
taking us around to the teams right
before graduation
I remember it kind of hitting me that I
don't actually know
oh here's how here's how naive I was so
remember the delayed entry program gave
people three chances of passing the test
okay okay so you could take the PRT and
if you passed it you were guaranteed
trying to go to buds first because
remember the way it was before you could
pass the PRT but then your gaining
command had to
had to had to agree to let you go to
buds instead of coming to them which
almost never happened right so you had
to go to the fleet for a couple years to
come back so the delayed entry program
was all about if you pass the PRT you
definitely go and it gives you three
chances to pass the PRT and then you get
like
some sort of promotion not a boot camp
promotion out of a school
and so um
yeah so I I took the test and uh I
remember his name is I remember his name
is petty officer Winkler he's a first
class he's Vietnam erasu not at like all
Vietnam errors he was a super cool guy
and uh and so they had like a morning
training for people who failed the test
to go in and work on their swimming work
like whatever they weren't good at go
work out so you had to get up a couple
of hours earlier an hour earlier and you
could go and and they excused you from a
little bit of your time at the in your
regular boot camp company because we
didn't have our own stuff back then as
you know and uh and so
I I just smoked the PRT and Winkler
really liked me and he's like hey you
should come in the mornings and you can
coach guys because obviously I'd worked
at a gym and I was like sort of a
personal trainer stuff anyway so I was
doing that and then got to be really
good friends with him and the other seal
motivator
and after the after I coached people in
the mornings I'd end up sitting in their
office shooting the shed they'd they'd
be drinking coffee I didn't drink coffee
and he said something about dive pay or
Hazard duty pay or something and I was
like what's that and he starts
explaining it to me
and this light bulb goes off of my head
I'm like
I'm gonna get paid
and he thought that was the funniest
damn thing he'd ever heard so he took me
around to every office like and tell
them what you just said to me and so I
and I literally uh I like I was just a
dumb kid like I just wanted to go do
this training I didn't I didn't know I
was going to get paid like why why are
you going to pay me because right I have
you're giving me a place to live you're
giving me clothes and then there's a
child Hall like yeah what do I need I
figure like I'm just gonna be training
to kill people or going to kill people
like what else what else am I going to
do why do I need money I didn't think
about people having families and kids
like you know you just thinking like oh
they're guys in the military that's what
he does that's all he does I had a
similar I was in my first platoon I
think it was my first platoon or
whenever I got paid per diem for the
first time oh yeah like they had to
explain it to me a couple times you know
you know you're getting that was a wild
concept okay you're going to the desert
and here's fourteen hundred dollars and
I'm like uh what's this for and they're
like for your food and I only make a
thousand bucks a month and give me
fourteen hundred dollars
uh wait but I mean I what about when I'm
not in the desert I still got to buy
food there yeah but when you're there
we're gonna give you money to buy your
food I'm like okay I'll take it it yeah
it took a while to comprehend that the
whole the whole thing when you got to
buds was there was there any challenges
for you at buds
yeah the runs uh I I was a what did you
weigh
2 30. now
and not not a not a fast runner
I was a great Sprinter yeah yeah I was a
fast food
human and uh and like when we did frog
Hill you gotta remember one time I was
talking to you you're like
you're like oh what's your way I mean
you're dead lifting that I was like dude
I can like I dead lift the most I've
ever deadlifted is like 505 or something
and you looked at me like I was scum
I was like damn that hurt bro
so yeah you're all fast twitching yeah
so the runs kicked your ass yeah
um I I struggled and I knew I would
because I I mean I struggled in
preparation so when I first decided to
join the Navy
the marine recruiter actually talked to
a seal
and had the and had the guy talk to me
so I had a phone call with a guy
and uh and he said
well it sounds like your biggest problem
is going to be running because I all had
done like I ran track and field but I
did like
I the furthest I the furthest I ever ran
was 400 yeah 400 meters right like that
was the furthest I'd ever run in my life
uh I'd never done a mile on a track
Never and uh so and I hated that like in
football and to be like take a lap
to warm up right I'm like I want to
smoke like what do you mean warm up like
I'm done like I come back from a labeler
what are you kidding me and uh
unfortunately my son inherited that for
me uh so this this uh seal Soul makes a
big problem for you is gonna be the run
you need to be running like 10 miles a
day I'm like I don't really
okay so I'm like I don't know where I'm
gonna run 10 miles so I go out into like
the Main Street that's all the one that
gets from the freeway down to my town
and it goes several miles the other way
so I clocked it off in my car and it's
five miles Michael I'm just gonna run
down to the end of this thing and back
10 miles a day I didn't even have any
shoes like I I owned like one pair of
shoes they're like top Siders and so I
just ran barefoot
down Concrete Street I just started
running 10 miles a day and I did it I
mean I'm sure I didn't do it every day
but I like my memory is it's like I just
did it every day and uh
and then when I got uh
and I and then I started timing myself
in the mile half because right we had a
PRT and I knew I had to hit a certain
time and that that I didn't degrade it
like I probably
I probably only beat that qualification
time for 30 seconds 20 seconds something
like that
um like when I and then when when I went
to a school I really focused on running
a lot
um and I did like a couple of 10ks and I
I got to where it's running like six and
a half minute miles and tennis shoes and
shorts on a road on the street right so
I think the cutoff time about like seven
and a half minutes or something and
pants and boots on the sand
so it was it was all I could do uh I
mean I was always in the Goon Squad I
was in the gun squad every run I was in
the good score but it was almost always
the first guy out because it was like
bear call races or Sprints or like
something like that and like hey that's
my bag baby in fact you remember frog
Hill out of the island yep it's like you
had to do pull-ups before I mean all you
had to do frog Hill I was so fast at
frog Hill and I and and unlike anybody
else I'm going through buds scared to
death that I'm getting kicked out every
every day every day like every second is
like they're about to figure out I'm
actually gonna be here and I'm getting
tossed right and so I I just like a real
just keep your head down like the most
humble time of my life was was Buzz and
I wasn't gonna bring any attention
myself
and I don't think I really realized I
did it uh because I think they had kind
of groups or something and I I mean I
just smoked everybody in my class like I
I think I was come I was almost all the
way back down before anybody got to the
top
and so then there's this one instructor
who decided I must be sandbagging the
runs because look how good he is at
running right and so so he just turned
on me and like you know I was just beat
down boy and then they got to where
they were dropping me for push-ups when
they started the class and I still had
to meet the time and then after a while
I was like you have to beat everybody or
you're still going to the search zone so
I had to what second place was like 40
push-ups or something I don't know I
don't remember I think I think it's like
20 40 60 or something like that through
the phases and so whatever it was in
second phase I had to do the push-ups
and then I Sprint and I would still win
and like I was really good at that and I
just sucked it at the Run you'd barely
pass the Four Mile time runs beer I mean
every run was like five four freaking me
diving across the Finish Line like I
mean in fact uh one of the instructors
because I was I was pretty good at
everything else like some of the
calisthenics stuff like flutter kicks
forever like I wouldn't like that that's
just too enduring for me like I couldn't
uh but but I was obviously like a
I'm pretty sure I was the biggest but I
was definitely like one of the top two
yeah he's a big dude to be going through
but let's finish budgeted 185.
oh damn
and uh I started buds at 174. I
graduated buds at 185. Holy so you and I
met in the middle yeah I I think they
called me like the cyborg gorilla or
something because like I lost all my
muscle mass and my torso
but my arms didn't get smaller so I
looked like
like I was just I was just a weird
looking thing but you know I could do
like anybody like you graduate but I
could do like 600 push-ups in a row
right uh now I remember going to the gym
the first time after buds
and I couldn't bench two plates
and now I was literally you were like I
I almost cried like I was sitting there
like going oh God like I had tears
rolling up in my eyes
oh my God you know because uh I mean I
wasn't super strong but I was I mean
definitely like well into the 300s in
high school right so I expected to be
stronger and I'm like I can't binge my
body weight right I'm weak uh but it
yeah obviously it comes back very fast
so yeah do you do you remember when they
started talking about medium twitch
muscle do you remember the time frame
that that happened
because I remember reading an
intermediate intermediate fibers I guess
maybe okay I just remember I was never I
wasn't like the fastest guy but I I
wasn't like the most endurance guy so
I'm like the loser that I couldn't win a
Sprint and I couldn't run I couldn't win
the freaking Four Mile time run right
and I I figured out eventually when I
started hearing about like intermediate
twitch muscle that there's certain
people that have this thing and that was
me and I was like oh yeah because like I
could put on a rucksack and just go
forever right uh in Jiu Jitsu like I
have really good endurance yeah I mean
have you seen me get tired no so I've
been training with him for like 10 years
never see me get tired I remember
training with you and like watching you
roll guys and you just have like sweat
pouring off your bed still still like
breathing through your nose and like
just calmly mashing people and I'm like
that killed me and jets like I because I
mean I'm good for like three minutes
if I haven't won in three minutes I'm
not gonna win like by the time by the
when you do like you know three minute
rounds or whatever after class by the
time I get something I mean I might as
well be rolling with the five-year-old
girl because I have nothing I have no
strength whatsoever yeah yeah but I I
just didn't have that that explosive you
know again like Max dead left like I'd
be embarrassed a bit dude I'm I'm just
pathetic yeah and that's just the way it
is I mean it's just a different you get
you get your certain genetic thing and
that's what you're gonna you can work on
it a little bit Yeah you can get to do a
lot of push-ups instead of a lot of
bench I guess apparently yeah yeah yeah
well I mean you uh
I mean nobody nobody is like
100 of any fiber right and like in
different muscles of your body you're
gonna have different makeups of them and
so like everybody everybody couldn't
train to some degree to get better to
get reasonably good at something if you
really work it's just like any it's like
your mental aptitude but like you would
have zero percent chance of being a good
marathon runner yeah you here's how
smart I am though when I was in medical
school in residency I knew that the
smart thing to do then was to start
doing triathlons because I was gonna get
good at this damn endurance thing
finally right so when I was in college I
worked full time and I went to school I
worked part-time and uh but it was a lot
of for part-time it's like 30 hours a
week um and then I went to school full
time uh and you know for half of it I
was married and had kids and whatever so
like I was burned in the candle at both
ends uh you know staying up late first
right get papers and right whatever
finals and all that and uh so all I
really had time to do is run
so I'd come home and I ran and ever and
it started like around the three miles
and then there's four and then five and
then six
and then I said you know I'm gonna do a
marathon
because you know whatever like I've
never been good at insurance I'm gonna
get good into it so I did a marathon
brutal like uh
like I I have the type of endurance
where like if I go slow I can go forever
yeah but I don't I can't go fast like if
I go fast and I go if I go anaerobic
once and hit like that black faster
threshold like I'm done like I'm done in
fact I did that in one of the triathlons
uh
so so anyway I did that and I started
doing well I'm going to do triathlons
and so I started with the super frog did
you how much weight did you have to lose
a bunch of weight or did you lose weight
while you're doing that or just go
Clydesdale yeah just doing Clydesdale
and something happened to me at some
point in my life uh it was after the
teams so it was during college I think
my body weight like settled out around
240. give or take five pounds right
nothing I did change that and to this
day nothing changes that I can starve
myself
like I can lose weight for a little
while but like give me two days and I'm
right back to 240. I can be like kind of
doughy and soft and out of shape and I
weigh 240 I can be ripped and like no
body fat 240. it's like that's just what
I weigh and uh so I was running
marathons at that at that weight
um and so I did the super frog
and uh because you know it's the
original like throwback to the teens
like it'd be cool
um and so I and they have a cut off time
right like if you don't finish by a
certain time and it's basically a half
Triathlon right yeah yeah it's a hacker
it's a house it's a half Iron Man so
it's 1.2 mile swim 56 mile bike ride and
half marathon
um and so I I do it and if you don't
make the cut off time then you're you're
dnf right did not finish same as
somebody who drops out
I made it by like three minutes I think
it was like seven and a half hours and
there's dudes doing this thing like this
guy's doing like two and a half hours
right and so I finish and barely make it
three years later I've been doing
triathlines the whole time right I ride
my bike to work or ride my bike back and
forth to school the hospital or whatever
um you know running whenever I can I
never really practiced a swim uh because
I I actually just did side sure because
my side trick was as fast as my crawl
anyway so I just did that
um and you can do that forever obviously
like after buds like you get so you get
so efficient at that movement I could go
20 miles today probably
um and so I
I do it again three years later I'm two
minutes faster after all that training
I'm like I'm going back to powerlifting
yeah I'm good at like this like uh I
went out when I was training it when I
was trading at OD Neto School uh
do you know yeah yeah so I was training
in his school and I was it was like
incorporating the jet training into my
bike right like right there no I was
biking to the hospital and then leaving
the hospital and stopping by there and
then going and so dad had like five or
six miles to my commute
and uh and I still gassed all the time
and I was like
like what the hell like because I didn't
understand the physiology at the time
and I'm like how can I still be gassing
like oh like I'm doing all this
endurance work and I'm still gassing on
the maps like I remember the first time
he had us do like
he put out like whatever the five or six
black belts and it's like you can roll
two minutes here and then and then the
last guy rolled with this him
I mean he just like thump me yeah fall
over it thump me like I couldn't do
you're like a dream for like a guy that
owns a school that's a black fella Cody
Odie probably is what do you think Odie
yeah maybe 170. yeah so he's just like
oh I get to beat up this seal yeah yeah
I always try to keep it on the download
it as a seal but it gets out eventually
right and then well even just so you're
just a jacked 240 pound dude yeah with a
white belt on yeah
um Jeff Glover Jeff Glover and I've seen
this now he the best the worst uh I
guess it's called the best the worst but
it's the easiest for him to go against a
guy that's big and strong like he he he
is if he sees the guy that's big and
strong he's like oh yeah I'm gonna have
fun with them and I've watched him do it
watch Like Big Jack guys come in and he
just is all over them and you see like
another guy that's more his size or a
guy that's you know uh long and lanky or
whatever it's more trouble for him but a
Big Jack guy he's like I got this fool
yeah I didn't didn't he do like some
sort of exhibition here or something
with he and another guy he likes yeah
he's a barred here or something he's
like watching two snakes yeah I mean
he's just like this I mean they just
rolled forever like from Oh Yeah from
position to position that position
attempt attempt at them just like I'm
like I I can't even follow that like
freaking nuts um all right so you get
done with buds did you did get rolled at
all no that's good uh and you're you're
what you're 18 19 years old
so I technically yes I was I was 19
because I graduated in
technically because we actually had
Christmas break before we graduated we
should have graduated so we're really
done with Buds and I think we had like a
13 Mile time to run right left or
something
or it wasn't timed right it wasn't
there's some time to it but it wasn't
the same as like yeah four miles I think
it was more like you better not you
better pass it type thing yeah but
there's I think there was a time on it
three hours yeah I think there was a
time limit but it wasn't two hours it
wasn't like the same consistent yeah
like everything else was like whatever
uh that's that same time I think it was
seven and a half minute miles was like
the cut off on all that stuff and that I
think it was a little longer but um so
that's all we had to do is come back and
do that and then we were graduating so
uh so I graduated technically in January
of 90. okay and then you got to go to
Airborne in March I would have turned
20. okay so yeah it's not end of night
yeah then we went to we were the first
class that they sent us a class oh
really they hadn't done it in a really
long time man do we get in trouble oh
yeah oh yeah we got and we were there
the first time anybody died
in Jump scroll really and the dude I
mean he was like from here probably to
uh probably to the mats like that far
away from me like I I heard that then
what happened to him we're doing combat
equipment and uh
he I don't know if his actually was bad
or whatever but he ended up inverted
with his leg cotton and uh and the
risers and uh
and a cigarette rolled to some degree
when he pulled his reserve but his Rock
was on top of it because it flopped on
it so he's 19 he's from Texas that's
horrible man and he just I mean I heard
that dude hit and then it sounded like
just like after you shoot a deer or
something you hear the
I remember that so clearly and then
anyway uh
we you know we'd go in the chow hall
there and you know how the those Army
kids are taking that school seriously
and we're we're cocky as [__] like on
you can't whatever this is a joke for us
and so we'd sit around and smoke and
joking the and the towel for like an
hour and like you know keep going back
and whatever and so this stars and
stripe reporter comes around he starts
trying to ask everybody questions an
army catcher you know eating like a
robot and then bolting out the door
right and uh
and so we were like hey
come here I'll tell you what happened so
we told them that uh we told him that uh
that the guy didn't hook up because he
was going to dor at the door
and the instructor pushed him out
of course we had no idea what went on
and they printed it and they said oh my
God As Told By Any Navy personnel and so
like then our whole class gets caught up
in front of the head of the school like
if you don't tell me who did this
throwing all of you out of course like
no one's going to say anything right I
remember like all right throw us all out
that's better than you getting rid of
one of our guys right it's better than
being a rat right and so nobody said
anything the school shut down for like
two weeks and we just got like hammered
on like all the time like all day every
day they're trying to break out and yeah
the dude they ended up printing our
attraction whenever but
um yeah the first time anybody died so
there's a couple of weeks there had been
other people that died at Dearborn
school they told us this is the first
time anybody's ever burned in
that seems impossible it does they put
out thousands and thousands I know
paratroopers every week now
maybe it's the first guy that died in a
while or something like that maybe but
they did they showed us they shut the
school down we're gonna get fact checked
on that one yeah I mean they shut the
school down and we did uh
I mean just like nothing for like two
weeks and then when we finally jocked up
to go again they were still super edgy
oh yeah and we sat like we set jocked up
and combat equipment for like six hours
waiting 100 to get in to get in the
plane and jump out for five seconds
yeah it was it was it wasn't a cool
wasn't a cool time so you end up
checking into you go to Team five yeah
um and this is what 19 1990 now in 1990
yeah stt what we could call it then yeah
inserted as QT and that's at the team
yeah every team did their own yeah yeah
that's what I went through today
[Music]
um you're a white one 77 177 what
classified
163 164 164. yeah uh yeah new guy always
um so you get your first platoon any any
big deal from stt
appreciate it Forward no we they we did
they just hand you an M60 and say here
you go yeah yeah you're a jacket which
was which was cool with me yeah because
like I I
hate
you know I hated uh M16 I'm like oh okay
A little poodle weapon
thinking I like the spring sound like
you know cap gun I want a real gun man I
loved the 60s they're not super
mechanical right like I I grew up like
working on everything and like super
mechanical so I was really good at
clearing the jams and knowing how to you
know work the weapon really well and I
really enjoyed it hell yeah oh yeah then
you so that's what you get your first
platoon yeah and first lieutenant rep 60
first lieutenant rep get some yeah and
actually halfway through my first
platoon I became the department lead as
a new guy right on uh and then and then
I was just like always first lieutenant
for my other two platoon just Motorhead
you're a Motorhead yeah so you're
getting in there so what do you and
you're going on deployment I mean
what's workup like what are you guys
focused on what's the big mission I know
when I was you know for my early
platoons it was always like we were
preparing for like one big mission that
we would pray would happen like we
wouldn't we as much as I prayed for war
which I did yeah I couldn't have dreamed
of like
a two decade long War like I thought if
we're lucky we'll get some kind of a
One mission you know there'll be
something will happen and if we're in
the right spot at the right time maybe
we'll get to do one thing yeah that's
how scarce it was yeah people don't know
that you're like competing like used car
salesman for any work that comes out for
special courses or I just like you have
to have somebody jockeying to try to get
the work was Gardner in your first
platoon no he was in uh you see my
sister did you guys get like rolled up
or something yeah yeah my my 21st
birthday
Jack uh
so we walk I can't remember I can't
remember any of the names of the bars
but we walk into this one bar that's
really common one
and uh Jason was standing up on the bar
when I when I walked in
chugged a beer and then like slammed the
bottle why
because I can
I'm like I'm gonna like this guy right
so that wasn't my birthday I take it
back that's like when we first that was
like a Tuesday night that was like the
first that's like the first time I'd
think I'd been out in town really you
know it wasn't a big deal because I'd
already obviously you could go drink at
any age but my 21st birthday is like oh
so the whole platoon well first of
course yeah the riggers tape me and
threw me and [__] Ripper so
um and it was so I was so stupid because
we had like a trailer right divided in
half and the pi did you guys have the
same thing
I missed it oh yeah right because of the
mountain too but yeah so we had the just
like a regular trailer and it was like
partition and there's a platoon space on
each side they had like a regular half
my
padlock on on the outside and so
uh we were walking up
we're walking up to our trailer and our
sister platoon was in there was in their
side and uh my lpo goes up and he like
puts their has been like while they're
while they're in these lock it and so I
think Ellie's locking them in right
and then we have our platoon meeting and
then he goes uh at the end of the
meeting
uh he looks around he says
hey uh whatever you guys do
I don't want you to Rico State buck up
and throw me [__] River
and I look around and every single guy's
holding a roll of rigor's tape and I I
totally missed this the whole time I'm
like oh you gotta be kidding me man
now I realize oh that side's locked
that's what that was about and it was
just a [__] fight man I mean it's like
45 minutes and uh finally got just
grabbed my balls and just started
squeezing my balls everywhere like
that's like and I'm gonna go fight Ender
okay all right everyone's a tough guy
tape me up some guy grabs your nuts and
starts squeezing them yeah and uh
anyways and yes we go we go out into
town and
I don't even remember how it started
like I don't even hardly remember the
fight at all but I like knocked some
Shore Patrol guy out
and just went to the bar because I was
drunk [__] and like I'll be fine like
he's unconscious so I go in the bar and
then when we come out of the bar
uh they're like there he is and like all
these people start swarming up and try
to run and then like I hit some other
guy while I was trying to run away and
they finally got us
um and then or got me and then uh
in a handcuffed me in front
and I'm like
you know you've been a drunk guys like
that's a dumb idea right and uh so I so
I started walking to the Paddy way it's
like a Toyota truck with like the
built-on kind of uh camper like you know
whatever like a Paddy Wagon thing and uh
and the dude that I the tour Patrol guy
that I'd hit was like standing there
holding the door smirking and like said
something smart and I [__] hit him
again with both hands in front of me
like he he went out cold and hit his
head on the bumper and I was like
oh that's really not good so then they
don't recognize how stupid we can be
yeah yeah they just don't know yeah so
then they throw me in the Paddy Wagon
and I'm drunk I just like through the
wagon Spin and I'm so drunk and so I lay
down on my back and put my feet in the
corners and then when we get to the jail
so when you when I get in there Jason's
in there and he's like hey man I'm like
hey and they like he I don't know what
he was in there but I don't even
remember and uh and they get us to the
police station and they pull everybody
out and I'm like I'm not getting out
and they they're trying to pull me out
they can't get me out and so they locked
the door and they go and they come back
and try to get me out again I won't get
out
and then they bring out this big
their big tough guy Shore Patrol guy
whatever and he's going to get me on so
they put him in and lock the door and uh
and I I managed to like put some
pressure on his shoulder and like pull
him into me and he and it was like
essentially breaking his wrist backwards
right like because he and he couldn't
get off of it because like the way his
body position like he was just half his
body weight was on his wrist and it was
inverted and I'm just pulling on him and
he's screaming they'd let him out and
then uh I'm still laying there and then
all of a sudden I hear at least maybe 45
minutes to go by and I hear my officer
go hey Buck I was like yeah I guess
let's go I'm like all right and I get
out they on handcuffed me and and I went
back to Barracks with him and then you
know your mat your Senior Chief whatever
goes and Smooths things over the next
day gives the guys a case of beer or
whatever this is the stupidest time like
we like all of our excitement was
self-induced and I was in for the first
Gulf War right like get the so the first
Gulf War shut my work up down was that
your first workout my first workout yeah
and uh and we were we were so we got the
cool thing was because of that whatever
they thought the mission set was they we
became a free fall platoon and so the
first thing I did was go to free fall
school I think I only had like
two or three more jumps whatever you get
an sdt it was like the only other jumps
I'd had other than jump school so I
never did Static line again right I just
uh unless it's in the water reproduct or
something um
yeah so we we uh
we got our our work up got I think
workups are like a year and a half then
right yeah and they get we got shut down
to about a year uh got compressed and
then we didn't end up going to go for
anyways because I think
maybe it's like half over or something
like you know how limited that whole
thing was and so then we deployed to the
pi and then uh Mountain Pinatubo blew
when they're out there and that that was
a
very interesting what'd you guys do on
that just like provide as much security
yeah so we so we were
so a lot of people don't know this but
like when that mount when Mount
pentatubo blew probably because it blew
and there was a typhoon at the same time
and so
you know Clark Air Base the Air Force
Base which was on a 45 minute drive or
something away
they had Boulders the size of this room
coming down from miles high in the sky
just like landing on buildings and cars
and whatever and uh that place was
demolished and but we just got all this
ash we got some rocks but like we got
all this Ash and the ash had a ton of
metal ore in it and it was mixed in with
the typhoon so you have like 70 80 mile
an hour winds with rain and then this
ash with all this metal in it and it was
and it was sticking it sticks to
everything and it looks like kind of
grayish snow
but it's super heavy and it collapses
there it's like all the buildings are
collapsing are are
PBS and our and our peers our floating
peers were sinking and all our buildings
are collapsing so they're like there's
like the first night of this thing and
they're like hey we all need to go down
to the unit and like save all the so we
go you know we should we we don't even
have shuttles we have bow doors right
like and uh and we're just in like a
boat ore of this stuff probably weighed
30 pounds like it was just super compact
and uh so we go and we shovel all that
off and then we're going up on the roofs
and we're trying to save you know the
buildings we are up on the paraloft and
uh there's no light right you can't see
anything we're wearing flight suits with
scuba mask and you could shine a
flashlight and you could about see your
feet pre-head lamp right that's so crazy
no one had thought of headlamps yeah and
so I get up to the top of the parallel
often I think you guys are going hey
over here over here over here and sound
like I'm walking their way and all of a
sudden I stop and I'm like
a
I feel like I'm going wrong like I'm
trying to remember what the building was
like I was like I feel like I'm going
the wrong way and I pull out a
flashlight and I look at my feet and one
of my feet like one of my toes are
hanging over the edge like one more step
I was gonna fall 60 feet and uh so
anyway we're shoving all this off and
then we go into like one of the big barn
kind of things
and we're shelling off and like
buildings are collapsing while we're on
them and we're like jumping off whatever
and so then we all kind of show up in
this and this Barn has like the big
i-beams supporting the roof right
and uh
we're in there and somebody's like I
think maybe we should get out of here
what if this one collapses and I look up
and I'm like there's no way this is
gonna
and we're like we all dive out like the
doors uh you know it's like this wide
the doors open this wide like 20 guys
get through that thing in like five
seconds you know and the whole thing
collapses and so um so there was no
power for like six weeks there's no
water there's no anything and there were
bodies laying in the ditches all over
the place of course in town they have
like generators going and everything's
going like two days later they're like
up and running like nothing ever
happened and then we had like the uh
they call them the NPA like it's
the Vietnam equivalent or the Philippine
equivalent of the Vietnamese communist I
guess
um and they start trying to infiltrate
the base and like get equipment and all
this stuff and we were closing the base
uh because there was so much damage and
the negotiations had failed I think we
offered him like 10 million dollars and
they went like 100 million dollars and
we're like sorry we're out of here
so we're going to close the base anyway
and so they started trying to come on
the Basin so we're like patrolling
against them like you know arresting
some of those guys and stuff and that's
like they're kind of like the closest
thing to combat that that we saw yeah
um and we had uh
drug interdiction with the FBI and stuff
you know it's like yeah the most
exciting thing I did
which is kind of one of the reasons I
got out is like you know it's just like
the same training trips over and over
again doing the same stuff over and over
again it's like
I don't think we're ever going to go to
war again like I'm gonna go do something
else you know yeah and then of course
while I'm in medical school 9 11 happens
so you did you did a couple more
platoons in team five yeah and like you
said like you're it's the 90s and you're
just going through work up it's always
fun I mean yeah it's super fun yeah
Hollywood seals is what we call it yeah
it was like I'm just super fun yeah and
you're well for me I was always like
thought the big Mish was coming and so I
was always just like hey this you know
we got to be ready in my mind I was
trying to be ready
um I wish I had your confidence in that
I was like we had Bill Clinton in the
white house we're never going to war
kidding me
so you do a couple more platoons and
then you're like all right did you when
you when you decided to get out did you
know you wanted to become a doctor no no
what was your plan when you got out
well so I started dating this girl who
became my first wife like after after my
first platoon
um I dated her through my second work up
and then I deployed and then I came back
and I was supposed to do like nine
months of shore Duty you know like work
in the department start school kind of
transition out and then I got thrown
into platoon because somebody got hurt
and so it kind of deployed actually
until supposed to be until the day I got
out but it ended up being like four or
five days after I got I was actually
technically out and I came back
um but anyway so I
she was in physical therapy school so
wait so you're dating each other you got
married did you say no we were dating at
the time you're dating and she was a
figure you date this you start dating
this girl you figure you're gonna get
gonna get out but you end up getting
thrown into a platoon you do the
deployment you come home you have no
plan and you're out of the Navy boom
right okay and she's going to a physical
therapy school yeah so by the time I
came back for my second deployment she's
like three months out of grad school and
she's working at San Diego Children's
Hospital
and
and I used to take her textbooks on
deployment and read them because I like
I was just interested in
you know physiology and anatomy and like
anything to make me bigger and stronger
and faster and whatever better
um and so I felt like I had an interest
in that but I didn't you know I'd never
done well in school I was convinced that
I was dumb really until I until I got in
it like in a school I did really well
like I at the top of my class and then
like I did really well academically and
budge
um and so I thought well maybe I'm not
stupid maybe I just like never really
applied myself but we'll see right so
you go like you know have a GED so I
can't get into any college I have to go
to at least a year of Junior College
probably too and so uh I went there and
like started setting the curve in every
class I I thought maybe it was going to
be like jet2 or something like an
athletic trainer maybe a physical
therapist if like things really worked
out great for me
um and to to apply to physical therapy
school you have to like have 2 000
volunteer hours right well that's that's
a year of full-time work right so
part-time work that's a couple of years
and so I'm like well I get I'll start
getting my volunteer hours in Nate hired
me after I volunteered there for maybe a
week and they're like we want you to
come work for us and so then I worked it
as a physical therapy assistant at San
Diego Sports Medicine Center
the whole time I was in college
and
uh that was like a healthcare Mecca they
had everything you know they had
orthopedic surgeons they had Sports
Medicine guys they'd Do's did MD said
podiatrists they had massage therapists
pts athletic trainers uh
uh so we we had everything and I I got
to know all of the people I got to see
everybody's work
and I'm standing in the hallway with a
couple of doctors
um because they're about my age right
because I because I you know been in the
teams first so they're maybe two or
three years older than me
and uh I got to be friends with them and
we're standing out in the hallway one
day and uh and
and they're telling me you should go to
medical school
right pump the braces Sparky like I
didn't like I'm like I'm close to
medical school
and so they're trying to convince me
that I can get into medical school and
I'm like no freaking way I can get I'm
getting into medical school and then the
the doctor that owned it Leroy she's out
here still and he said he steps out of
his office and he goes Kirk
I didn't even know he knew my name right
here it's like Kirk
the question isn't whether you can get
in the question is would you go if you
got in
and I said of course he goes well then
you kind of have to try don't you I was
like [__] trapped you yeah like that's
right and then I ended up going to work
for him when I got out of the Navy like
my first year of the Navy I went back to
his practice he had a concierge practice
in Point Loma out here and uh yeah
um but that that's how that came about
man and and
I I mean I was fully planning to be an
orthopedic surgeon because I'm like a
mechanical dude and I like I like the
succinct like broken not broken yeah hey
this is broke I'm gonna put some bolts
and screws in there and plates and it's
not gonna be broken anymore and that's
it and then I'm gonna go on and do it
again uh I don't want to look at
anybody's freaking anion gapper like
care about what medications are online
doesn't interest me I wanted to go fix
things and uh
and then in in the Navy you have to do
an operational tour before they'll let
you finish residency so you do like your
first year
and then they you have to go out to the
fleet if you don't if you don't uh so
wait sir you already gotten commissioned
or were you planning to go back in the
Navy what was that oh yeah I totally
skipped that part yeah so when so when I
decided to apply for medical school
pre-internet so I went to the bookstore
and started looking through the Kaplan
books to see like what schools would I
be competitive for with my with my GPA
and my MCAT and all that
and that's when I found out this Navy
had its own school I was like no way are
you kidding me and uh so I look into
it's like they'll pay me to go to
medical school instead of the other way
around and of course I'm married and
have a kid and I have a kid on the way
dang uh I'm like well that makes a lot
more sense right like I wasn't excited
to go in the Navy trust me like I you
know I was in the team that's a good fit
for the teams but I wasn't a good fit
for the Navy I knew that and uh and I
was like all right well uh I'll do this
right and I and I knew that there was
you know this eight year commitment
afterwards and I was like well I'll go
back to the teams for a while and I'll
like give back to the community who
saved me from prison or you know
whatever I was going to end up if I if I
didn't have you know something to uh
Channel my anger with right and uh so I
I did you know when you do your
operational so she got commissioned in
2000 go to ois
Connecticut basically the knife and fork
School
they gave me some kind of award there
it's ridiculous I don't I think I did
like I participate in like 25 of that
school
they couldn't make pants for me I have
really big legs and become a normal
waist and they kept making they're like
trying to make khaki pants like from
scratch like these girls and they were
ridiculous I mean and it was just like
they kept trying all this stuff so I
never had a uniform and I'd be like well
I gotta go to I gotta go to the uniform
store again and that's all I did for
like three weeks was like try to get a
uniform to fit and then uh and and so
and then they gave me some sort of award
as comical
um and then uh go to medical school
and uh
then from there I did
uh you know there was some Hoople I
won't get into but uh
ended up coming back to San Diego to do
internship which is the first year
residency essentially and then you have
to go out to the fleet do you do that
Balboa I did it yeah and uh
the you do that and if and then after
that year if you just say hey I just
want to come back as soon as possible
then they just send you out to some
fleet job you're probably gonna go 32nd
Street be on the ship or something right
but if you go to flight school you can
be a flight surgeon and go to dive
school and and a UMO school in
Connecticut and then you can obviously
go back to like arguments or the dodging
or something like that
so I was like ah I'll do demo and I'll
go back to the team for a while then
I'll come back and finish residency
and uh
I I went to die school and then at the
end of it there weren't there weren't
any orders for the teams so they put me
on at the submarine Rescue Unit out here
on the end of Point Loma okay no not
dude I'm sorry it's at the end of uh
North Island now and that was like a
policy job really because a lot of
people
don't realize this but like every
country that has submarines
like they all they all have this
agreement that will will rescue each
other's submarines even our enemies like
China Russia doesn't matter like your
submarine goes down on our Waters and
it's savable we'll use our system to
save your guys because technically these
systems can go anywhere in the world but
with a realistic time windows it's
probably not in realistic to like fly it
over there and set everything up so
you're going to be much better off if
the country that you're closest to saves
them and so then you have to make all
these agreements like who whose patients
are they going to be whose dive tables
are we going to use if we have to
recompress them like what like what's
going to be our Pro and so that's all we
did was travel around the world and meet
endless meetings and come up with new
policy
um and then uh then had the opportunity
to either go back to the hospital
or go to the teams I was like I really
feel like I should do that and so then I
go back to the teams
and that's right when they called it I
think they were calling they're still
calling it The Human Performance program
and then switch the tech classic program
and so I got there right when they were
funding the build out of that clinic
nice
of course I was a perfect fit for that's
a freaking PT clinics like duh like I
did this for I did this all through
college like I know what I'm doing so
and then like and there's a great time
like I got to be there when we hired
everybody like when when we hired the
first you know the first athletic
trainer the first PT the first
nutritionist the first strength and
conditioning coach like which is crazy
to think about everything that you're
just saying it's the first the first the
first the first because in 2009 I have
any of this stuff yeah like it was just
like your PT was whatever
your CEO or whatever your Exo is into so
your exit like to run and swim guess
what you were doing run swim or swim
around here if you got injured it was
like yeah like you dealt with it it's
like figured out whatever your corpsman
could do for you because you weren't
going to drive across the bridge and go
to rehab and Pete it freaking Balboa
yeah and even if you do that what are
they rehabbing a sailor at Balboa for
they're rehabbing him to like get out of
the Navy with a medical retirement or
whatever that's what they're rehabbing
him for in the teams the guys want to go
back to work right like I'm hurt you
make me better now right yeah I've got
to go to nylon in two weeks make me
better right now right that's the other
thing you're traveling so much like how
much rehab do you really have unless
you're gonna get pulled out of your
platoon but you might as well die before
you do that like just let your arm fall
off like maybe you'll still be able to
make it you know that that happened with
a stomp so stump came over and saw me
when he was getting out
and he's like I didn't know him uh I
knew he I knew who he was and uh
and he he comes over and he's like hey
you know I'm I'm getting out in like two
days and everybody keeps telling me you
should look at my record so here it is
she gives me a record just like paper
thin and I open it and his and his
discharge physical it's like good to go
everything's good
I'm sitting there I'm like didn't you
get shot he's like yeah like you know
now that's in here he's like does that
matter I'm like yeah that matters like I
I said regardless of how you feel now if
you start having some serious problems
and you need surgery revision like big
care like that's you know what what if
you know what what if and so he's he's
like oh okay and so then I check into it
I'm like dude you're gonna have to stand
there and nothing he was pissed man oh
I'm sure and he ended up he ended up uh
I did I just saw him recently and
I was like she's still pissing me about
that he's like no best thing ever how
much longer how much longer do you think
I think he ended up in like in another
year damn because he had to go through a
medboard oh for sure yeah but I mean
there was nothing in there there's
nothing in his record that's just it was
literally just like signed off like good
good good good like I see medical record
like I said when I was there what's your
answer to the questions like fine yep
how's your shoulders fine knee fine neck
fine yep so you got surgery yep it's
fine now yeah everything is just fine
fine can I get out of here now yeah I
want to leave yeah like like you're
saying at the beginning no
nobody wants to see the doctor but more
to the point nobody trusts the doctor
all right because that's the guy who can
put you on the bench what's the worst
thing you do at a team guy pull him out
of his Stone I give you something that's
disqualifying I say oh you have a
problem you need meds you're
disqualified you can't take any real
medication in the teams
and uh
you know that that I mean interestingly
because of that Nuance that's that's why
I ended up learning everything that I
learned as a SEAL Teams and doing what I
do now I mean less than one percent of
what I do now has anything to do with
what I learned in medical school or
residency or anything like it's it's all
outside I was talking
to a guy that was oh it was Jason I
think it was Jason but you know he'd
come from where the the baseball or
football where did you go yeah yeah uh
yeah choose baseball yeah and maybe it
wasn't him I was talking to somebody
that was football
and um
he said something like uh and he worked
at Bud's medical and at Bud's medical he
he said he would see like
whatever the number was 40 cases of
patella femoral syndrome a week yeah and
he said when he was with the NFL he saw
like two cases right and it was like
that for every like shin splints you're
if you're at Bud's medical you see 50
cases a week of shin splints and every
just go down the list of shoulder injury
this and so the team's the same way like
you oh shoulder injury knee injury like
you're just gonna see so many of it you
get so good at it right uh that it's
it's like an environment where you're
just going to learn so much so so you
were in this critical role as this thing
kind of stood up where the the teams
started taking
the health of the seal
more like as serious as we could
possibly take it yeah and doing
proactive stuff too right so what did
you what does being in the teams do to a
dude
well so this is how it all got started
right
um we built that facility we hired all
these great people like you said pull
people from pro teams from Olympic
Training Center for like top-notch top
tier colleges and so so we have all
these brilliant people that are great at
their job now I'm the dumbest guy there
right because like I'm just a guy who
worked into sports medicine center when
I was in college and like I don't really
know any of this stuff so what does the
Navy do when you're the Domino's guy put
you in charge right so later well now
you're going to supervise all these
people and so like I now have the
supervisory position and and the rehab
facility and uh so as you know like my
office was in between those two sides of
it
and so guys should be over there doing
rehab and
you know I had been a seal recently
enough to where there's still a ton of
guys in there that I went through
training with and that I deployed with
and so I had a good enough reputation
the guys trusted me and then come and
shut the door and like hey let me tell
you what's really going on with me right
because like you said fine fine fine
like fine fine everything's good
everything it's like you know they'll
put rigor's tape over a bullet hole if
they had to just be like you know I
don't I don't want to get put on the
bench I don't trust this dude
um and so they came in I can't remember
who the first guy was at this point but
it comes in it's like you know what's
really going on man
he's talking about
wait you know I can't remember anything
right he comes in a room he gets Wise
air leaves oh Remember come back forget
leaves his house five six times in the
morning getting this car back up oh I
forgot my badge and going oh forget
that's right
and uh and then they'd be saying you
know my motivation just sucks my
concentration sucks like sitting I sit
in meetings I can't I can't follow
anything anybody's saying like my
attention span is like two seconds or I
can be given the brief and I'm not
interested and like you know but they're
Team guys so they're still getting after
it but they just don't feel like getting
after it and they're like basically I'm
getting cold or weaker fatter you know
like they're following the nutritionist
advice they're following the strength
and conditioning advice they're doing
everything exactly how they should do it
and they just they're getting weaker
they're getting fatter they're getting
slower they're getting Moody sex drives
down sexual performances down right
um and just really all performance
issues right so
um I'm not as fast I'm not as strong I'm
not and then they'd be like yeah but
maybe I'm just getting old and I'm like
yeah man you're 34 like it's over for
you right you're screwed uh you might
just go go sex start your sick right now
man and uh so
I honestly didn't have the slightest
idea first guy comes to my office and
tells me this I'm like
I'm bewildered I don't know so I'm like
I'm gonna do a bunch of labs
and uh
I mean it's first important to preface
this with when I first got there the
department had was actually a PA
so a physician's assistant was
supervising The Physician and
he'd been in the Navy language he's a
former team guy and one of the first
things he tells me in his office he's
like hey these guys are going to come to
you and expect some special treatment
I'm like yeah
it's like we can't give it to him like
why wouldn't I give him
he's like you have to treat everybody
the same
I mean no it's in the name Special
Forces like they get special treatment
like we're we're here because the team
guys are not here for tech support like
those guys can go to the hospital right
like if we have the capacity we'll see
them but like I'm here to help the team
guys he's like you can't think of it
that way and I'm like no we're not going
to get along then because that's what
I'm gonna do like I'm here to help I'm
here to help the community I'm gonna
give a [__] my my co was a supply
officer right a Groupon I mean [__] with
that guy wants I don't care like I'm
here to help my my boys man I'm gonna do
it so so everything I did was
in that vein and I and it wasn't popular
it wasn't possibly popular with the
seals it's popular so they came in and
they tell me this story about all this
stuff and
nothing they're saying and this is just
like repeal one guy a day one guy a week
ago she's like word of mouth so there's
like one and then one and one and then
two and then four and then and you know
I'd say
okay three months after the first guy
came in and had probably seen 100 guys
right and now I mean I could have told
them their story but I'd listen I'd take
notes and listen let them tell it and
they all told me the same thing
they've since they've done some research
and they're now calling this operator
syndrome I was calling it The Seal
syndrome and the syndrome basically
means here's all the symptoms
we don't know why and so it's a syndrome
right uh and so I'm just like well I'll
just test a bunch of labs and see like I
don't know I was doing uh 98 blood
markers so they're going to the hospital
giving like 17 bottles of blood
and then again everything that should be
high was low and everything should be
low what's high like their anabolic
Behavior super low catalog stuff really
high they're
inflammation really high oxidation
really high insulin sensitivity even
nowhere near what you would expect it to
be on a guy this fit and this in shape
and just eating this way
um and I didn't have the slightest idea
I'm just like
I don't know I don't know and then I
don't know maybe 50 or 60 guys into it
somebody said to me
he takes Ambien every night
and I thought like I seem to say that
yeah so I put a initial I remember like
doing a few days I was in khakis like
some days you just remember she's super
clear like the way I sit and at my desk
and like remember putting this note at
the margin
and then after he left I I kept Shadow
files because
none of the teammates wanted to stuff in
the record so I'm like I'm I'm just keep
a shadow file I'll give it to you when
you leave yeah or when I leave
um you you do what you want to with it
um so I I checked my shadow files every
single guy who'd been in my office was
an ambient 100 of them
and I was like huh
I wonder if that could be it now I took
pharmacology in medical school
so I knew how Ambien worked
but I didn't know enough of like I knew
it acts like Gaba right Gaba is a
neuropeptide and
like you heard a Gabapentin you give it
for nerve pain because it slows down
their function essentially right okay
um
and I'm like but I don't know enough
about sleep to know why that's
significant or what kind of does in
sleep I don't know I didn't have a
single class on sleep in medical school
[Music]
and
uh
and you know the way the pharmaceutical
industry works
yeah when they apply for FDA approval
they own the research and they give the
FDA what they want to give them they
don't give them what they don't want to
give them and but then if they ever get
sued in court they have to pull up the
skirt and show everything so that had
happened with Ambien like right before
this happened and so they were getting
sued
and so now we knew the the real side
effect profile
um and so I just had to learn a ton
about non-traditional medicine I had to
learn a ton about sleep I thought maybe
it was adrenal fatigue like I was trying
which isn't even like a real thing uh
but
um yeah that was kind of like the
alternative medicine thing a little
drink off the table it's like an HPA
mismatch that there's some validity to
it but just it's really not like the way
it's proposed but I was I was having
some success doing that like
um but it wasn't huge and then but I
noticed like everybody's testosterone
was low everybody's growth hormone was
low like low low right
um but in medicine
like I'm a western trained medical
physician right so I know how to
recognize and treat disease what do I do
if it's not disease right it's within
the bell curve
but
it probably should be higher but there's
no right so the chair at UCLA the chair
of Endocrinology at UCLA had done this
research where he he stratified the bell
curve for testosterone and broke it into
quintiles so 20 so 80 to 160 to 80 right
and the top quintile you had the lowest
risk of death for many cause
the lowest risk of any disease every
quintile you go down it doubles so by
the time you're in the fifth quintile
that's 16 times you're 16 times more
likely to die of any cause you're 16
times more likely to have any disease
every guy who came in to see me was in
that quintile now if that were magnesium
it would be medical malpractice to not
give everybody magnesium and keep them
in the upper coin top but because
athletes use tear testosterone to cheat
in sports it's political so you don't
give that right that's a that's a No-No
so I wasn't about they weren't about to
let me give guys testosterone but then I
learned hey when you're sleeping that's
when your testosterone is made like
that's when everything's rebalanced all
your hormones the most anabolic time in
your life is the first sleep cycle right
you go through your first sleep cycle
and most the most of that is deep sleep
deep sleep has the lowest stress
hormones the catabolic hormones that
you'll ever have in 24 hours and
uh and has the highest anabolic so most
of your repair right obviously when you
work out you don't get stronger weaker
you damage yourself when it repairs it
comes back stronger well that's
happening while you're asleep
so I thought so once I learned like what
goes on when you go to sleep and what I
had going for me was you know the teams
had already done some great work and I
had a great reputation because this is
like 2009 right 2010 and uh so I could
call up anybody be like hey I read your
book or I saw your Ted talk or heard
your lecture
um and I'm the doctor for the West Coast
sealed team so I was wondering if I
could train with you or consult with you
on clients whatever everybody was like
eager to help right that's awesome so I
got to learn a lot really quickly and I
start and I started trying to tell the
leadership that I thought that
a lot of their performance issues uh are
chronic injuries and our you know just
guys not feeling good not performing
well not feeling motivated not being
resilient
um I said I think a lot of this is from
their hormones okay I had the proof that
their hormones are they had the hormones
of an 80 year old man
uh and an 80 year old fat man actually
and uh
and I said I think it's sleep was that
everybody was like that I remember I
remember you talking to me you're like I
mean I was good and you were like you're
like dude you're free you told me you
know we had the testoster 17 year old
football player I was like yes yeah yes
there there are some people who
who just get through like for whatever
reason they stay resilient you know but
but but I obviously have a biased sample
because people are coming to me it's
because they have problems so like
everybody so you were just getting me
because I was retiring and like here I
am right I got it so most of the guys
were coming to you they feel like [__]
yeah and they're just coming to you like
broke and you please help me right so
then once I figured out the Ambien thing
I started digging into that uh which by
the way I've never taken Ambien yeah
you're super unique yeah
I I had uh I had the corpsman pull pull
medical records and look and 85 of our
Command of the West Coast 85 of the West
Coast SEAL Teams had a prescription for
Ambien yeah whether or not they were
taking it I don't know but like my doc
we were on deployment my Doc's like hey
hey we need to get he was like see he
didn't even need to tell me but he was
just telling me like Hey we're we're out
of Ambien or like we're almost out of
Ambien I got to get more I'm going to
whatever and I was kind of like
I didn't really think much of it because
like I said I'd never I've never even
tried it I don't even know what it feels
like but guys were freaking on Ambien
like it was like it was uh eating M M's
man right and so what is it does it Jack
up your yeah so so they thought so the
way they used to get people to sleep was
with benzos like Valium right and turns
out if you overdose on those you quit
breathing and you die uh and they're
super hard to get off of right that's
what happened to Jordan Pierce yeah like
super hard to get off of
so they found these Z drugs so
Gaba is this neuropeptide that basically
slows neurons down right so when you're
when you go to sleep
uh one of the primary things that's
happening in sleep is your neocortex so
the part of the brain that you think of
as the human brain the wrinkly bit uh
that's where like all your motor
function is all your sensory and all
your processing of that like your
interpretation of of the world that's
how you interact with the world with
that part right
so that that slows down and you quit
interacting with the world you quit
paying attention your senses still work
obviously right because I can turn on
the light and your eyes you know still
sense to light you know wake up all
right I can make a loud noise so you're
all your senses are still working you're
just not paying attention to them so gab
is the primary
neuropeptide that's making that happen
so the pharmaceutical industry the way
they work is like well if we figured out
this one step of this process then we
can supercharge that stuff right so now
this is going to bind at Gaba receptor
but it's going to do a hundred times
more than Gaba does
and that was benzos and then the Z jugs
were like a thousand times what Gaba
does what's a z
that's a category so that's like uh
Ambien and Lunesta and there used to be
a third one I can't remember and these
are like a thousand times that's a
thousand times the effect of Gaba so
what was happening
this is just dissociating people so so
they would take this and basically they
quit interpreting their senses but they
could still be awake
and so the reason they were getting sued
is people were like driving down and
doing lizard brain stuff they're driving
down picking up prostitutes they're
driving down and eating you know oh God
fifty hundred dollars worth of fast food
they're going to Vegas and gambling
their life savings away and mortgaging
their house and and wake up the next day
down here and remember it they have no
recollection of it whatsoever
and so that's what they start that's
what they're getting sued is it somewhat
addictive to Ambien it is for this
reason so
so yeah the first thing that happens
obviously the blue light goes out of our
eyes that change that makes some changes
in our brain
um and act and melatonin gets secreted
everybody tired of that person it's a
it's a hormone in your brain uh and
that's like the initiation of everything
right that's the as uh Matt Walker calls
it the starter pistol which I think's a
great metaphor so that initiates
everything and one of the primary things
that happened is Gaba comes in and slows
down the brain you quit paying attention
to your environment your body
temperature goes down and like that's
what makes you feel sleepy
so
um
if your your bodies are really smart
machine right it's efficient it's not
going to do anything it doesn't need to
do that's why if I give you testosterone
you quit making testosterone why the
hell are you going to spend energy
making it you're getting it for free
so if I give you Gaba and it's having a
thousand times the effect of Gaba or I'm
sorry if I give you a z drug I guess
having a thousand times the effect of
Gaba
all the receptors for Gaba we only need
one one thousandth of them because you
have all you have all of this freaking
Gaba everywhere like you don't need all
these receptors you know so
what happens is you down regulate
receptors and now you quit taking that
you're Gava deficient no matter how much
Gaba you have in your brain because you
need a thousand times what you would
ordinarily have just to be normal now
because you have so few receptors and
then the receptors take six to eight
weeks to come back nobody can wait six
to eight weeks to start sleeping again
right so they get they're really hard to
get off of too so that's why the Ambien
becomes addictive yeah so people can't
quit it because it's just making them
normal it's the same thing when people
take you know 50 milligrams or even 10
milligrams of melatonin it's like your
brain only makes about six micrograms
from the time the sun goes down until
you wake up you're taking 10 milligrams
all at once way more than your and
you're going to down regulate receptors
and now when you quit taking melatonin
you're melatonin deficient because you
don't have enough receptors how long
does it take to get back to where you're
producing medicine again well you're
still producing it it's just like you're
producing a normal amount with maybe a
tenth or 1 100th of the receptor so
you're just you're deficient because you
need both it doesn't matter how much
you'll get them back eventually The
receptors yeah it takes like six to
eight weeks uh you know ssris are very
similar like they're working on
serotonin reuptake and they're working
on receptors and it takes like six to
eight weeks to really start working and
takes six to eight weeks to recover from
and guys that do testosterone you you do
you ever start making that again if you
go on if you're on testosterone it
depends on how long you're on and what
you do while you're on it right so there
are things that you can do to maintain
testicular volume and function uh
most Doc in the Box guys don't do this
you know they're just like here's what
this monster and then and most of the
most of the guys that I end up seeing
you know they're they're being seen by
some guy who's giving them like two or
three hundred milligrams once a week or
once every two weeks
just getting like this huge surge
they're going super physiologic for a
few days they turn into a caveman for
like two days and then they down
regulate their receptors and that
testosterone gets converted into
estrogen and estrogen is the signal in
your brain to tell your brain how much
testosterone you have so if your
estrogen is high your brain assumes that
it's from testosterone so now you quit
producing as much testosterone and so
they get this peak now they down
regulate their receptors right and they
down regulate their own production and
so after a few months of that once all
the receptors have changed and all the
physiologies change
now they're super physiologic for maybe
a day or two and they're normal for a
day or two and now they're low the whole
rest of the time some guys that's two
weeks and so they'll always come in and
be like hey I started this and I felt
great and now I feel just like I did
before I started and I'll say
how much are you taking how often like
yeah are they are they looking at your
DHT are they looking at your estrogen
are they looking at your sexual and
binding globulin are they looking like
are they looking at anything other than
your testosterone are they even looking
at your free testosterone because total
testosterone really doesn't matter how
much of it is available
um and so like this is true with every
hormone anything anything any hormone I
give you
you're going to quit making it now there
are things that I can there's things I
can give you that will cause you to keep
making testosterone while you're taking
testosterone it's not perfect
but those guys that can come off of
testosterone probably be okay they're
they're still going to be bad off right
because they they weren't able to make
enough when I met them so now they're
going to be a little worse than that
when they get off and so like what I was
doing with the team does is I was first
doing it with like all supplements first
I was getting guys to sleep and getting
them off of Ambien right and that's that
just came from me and I couldn't just
say quit taking your Ambien because our
in our community one is good two is
better and three is probably great so
they're taking like three Ambien with so
they're taking seven they're taking
three ambient with like a couple of
cocktails and then they're waking up at
4 30 not intentionally you know they're
waking up at 4 4 30 and they're like
can't go back to sleep so I'm gonna go
into the gym I'm gonna work out really
hard today I'm not gonna take any breaks
I'm gonna work all day when I come home
tonight I'm gonna be tired and I'll go
to sleep I'm like all right how long
have you done that like three years keep
going like tonight's the night I think
right like obviously obviously it's not
working right
um and so like once I learned how Ambien
destroys REM sleeps like 80 percent of
REM sleep goes away and it knocks out
about 20 percent of deep sleep
alcohol does exactly the opposite
so destroys deep sleep gets rid of about
20 so when I sent these guys in for
sleep studies
99.9 stage two sleep so they weren't
getting any deep sleep any REM sleep do
they wake up in the morning I feel like
[__] yeah how do they even I don't even
know how they survived it honestly like
and that's one of the things about
medicine proves to you how little we
know because
that should kill them it should kill
them in a couple of weeks because that's
the same as getting no sleep you would
think uh but this is what you know the
ambient lawsuits kind of
were fortunately out to where I could
learn all that so I couldn't just take
away their ambient and alcohol and say
suck it up buttercup right like I had to
give them something so I I did some
research and came up with a bunch of
things and they were having to go to all
the just pre-amathons they're having to
drive around to three different stores
and get all the ingredients and try to
travel with it and it was a pain and so
you know they really bring me into
making a product out of it um to make it
easier for them
um so I you know I I figured out that
sleep was a huge component and that that
was causing
probably a lot of their low testosterone
and then there's things I can give you
like the precursors to testosterone like
DHEA and you can do a form of DHEA 7
Keto DHA that can't be converted into
estrogen so that's good right I give you
zinc citrate which will decrease the
amount of estrogen you make from your
testosterone
and then like some guys I was giving a
pharmaceutical called a remodex and that
blocks estrogen conversion too so it was
called a roamatase inhibitor and so
just with like DHEA pregnenolone
which is another precursor to the
testosterone pathway and uh some zinc or
Arimidex and getting us to sleep
guys were tripling quadrupling their
testosterone levels over six months 46
months right
um yeah I one of the CEOs out there
um he got like
and a couple years I was treating him
here like three PRS like like weight
lifting and running and like say
something else and like in his 40s like
this is the best he's ever been in his
life because he's you know he's been
broken down
we and like our community has some of
that just because of the chaotic sleep
anyway right just because well tonight
you're working and then
tomorrow you're working too and then you
know and now we're gonna travel and
we're gonna go over here we're gonna do
this and like and so every like you
sleep when you can obviously right and
so it's chaotic and if you aren't
aligned with your circadian rhythm sleep
is nowhere near as valuable
and uh so I got I got guys sleeping and
they had huge performance gains uh there
are a few older guys that I couldn't get
them to make enough testosterone to be
in the number quintile
so I think when they they they like shut
me down and
had me under investigation for a while
and like I I mean I essentially
sacrificed my career for like there was
no way I was getting any kind of Navy
residency or anything because I I was
just in trouble all the time with bumed
or the hospital or warcom whatever like
everybody who's um and even like my what
were they mad about
um that I was practicing outside of my
scope
that I was uh
like I was giving people what's called
Myers cocktails when I thought that it
was adrenal fatigue it's IV vitamins
apparently I'm not allowed to do that as
a doctor and uh I got in a lot of
trouble for that
um the Arimidex
ignorant doctors will say it's a cancer
drug why are you giving somebody a
cancer drug
it's not a cancer drug you [__] I mean
you give it to women with breast cancer
because their breast cancer is estrogen
sensitive and you want them to make less
estrogen has nothing to do with cancer
like you just don't want them to have
estrogen it's an it's an estrogen
blocker that's all it is
um so yeah I I just like everything I
did
you know and and all it takes because I
was a junior doctor right like all it
takes is for somebody senior to me
anywhere in the medical chain be like
he's doing what why is he doing that
like no we can't allow that and so then
they call warcom and complain that just
Rogue doctors doing all this crazy
Voodoo stuff that's what it's called
like voodoo
and when even when I when I told the
leadership
uh Andrew uh
Chrome guard with Alex Alex kronegard uh
he was
the Commodore at the time and he was
super receptive like he's smart educated
on all this stuff but everybody else
like
literally laughed me at their office
going you gotta be kidding me
their testosterone's low because they
aren't sleeping right doc like you got
some problems and uh but then I started
getting results and people started
performing better and were to mile
spread and then they started having me
lecture at the pre and post retreats
and then I you know that's when I like
was sharing the stage with like Rob wolf
and Welborn and Crasher and like all
those guys and then they started
inviting me on podcasts and invited me
to other symposiums and stuff and like
that's kind of where my career went
because of what I was doing with our
with our guys so what what year did you
end up getting out of the Navy January
13. so you retired from the Navy of
January 13th I didn't retire but I got
you know 19 years are you serious yeah
yeah bro well so but medical school is
like uh the academy so it only counts
retro so you have to do 24 years to
retire
so I would have had to stay in five more
years okay and there was there was
nowhere for me to go I mean I was gonna
end up in Antarctica or something like
yeah that burned I'd burned a lot of
bridges to do what I did yeah so then
what'd you do when you punched out so
you kind of had I went and worked at the
concierge practice and uh in Point Loma
with the doctor who talked me into
becoming a doctor and then he wanted me
to succeed him in that practice and take
it over
and it was exactly what I thought I
wanted you know um and I was already
doing some private Consulting like
people heard me on podcasts and be like
hey I want to work with you and so it's
sort of telemedicine like Zoom stuff
um Skype in those days I guess um and uh
so I was doing some of that and then but
of course when I left I created like
this vacuum because the next guy who
came to the teams was just like
a doctor like a regular doctor who's
just waking biting his time did you try
and do like a turnover of what you had
learned with him yeah but but he was
like I want to stay in the Navy yeah
after seeing what happened to me there
wasn't anybody who's gonna be interested
in doing what I'd done has the world
caught up with these protocols yeah
yeah like I'd say maybe four or five
years after I got out like Socom hired
me to come and lecture there and like
lecture all their medical stuff and like
damn Nick hired me to come and do a
lecture and teach all their medical
stuff and I I consult them on all those
guys on a fairly regular basis
BH Liddell heart who wrote the book
called he wrote a bunch of new countless
books but you know he's uh he's uh World
War one guy fought at the psalm and he
he wrote the book that I love called the
indirect approach but one of the things
he says in that book is the first person
with an idea
if they stick with that idea and they
hold on to it guess what they've become
a martyr so and you look out through
throughout history like if you have an
idea and you you're like hey this is the
way it should be
you you end up a martyr and that's kind
of like what happened to you because it
takes a while for ideas to get accepted
he rolls out this one example of with uh
the major changes that have been made to
warships over the past whatever it is
200 years every major change that came
like no one accepted it until like
somebody got martyred and then you know
like going from uh whatever from sale to
like steam yeah those first guys like
are you an idiot what are you gonna do
when you're out at 10 there's no call
you're an idiot yeah like where you can
sail forever and sure enough these guys
get fired and then the next guy says you
know we should make the holes out of uh
out of metal instead of wood idiot how
are you gonna repentless
all those things and that's what happens
so if you're the if you're the first
person to roll out if you're not careful
now you can be careful you can get it
done
in a more this is what he talks about
yeah a more indirect manner so if you
had said all right I'm going to be like
super strategic and I'm gonna run this
up to change it would have taken longer
you had to you had to tell a bunch of
guys I can't do anything for you now you
know it would have taken you seven years
or whatever right so I'm not saying it
would have been it's just that that
indirect approach is how is the only way
to well I'm not the only way but it's
probably the only way to avoid becoming
a martyr but for you you're sitting
there looking at people that are hurting
and you're like all right I'm gonna help
you guys need help right now like it's
totally totally worth it like I I was
fully aware of what I was doing I'm not
I'm not whining about it like I knew
what I was doing at the time I had a I
had a quote taped in my monitor from
Buckminster Fuller who said it said uh
never fight the system create a superior
system to make the old one obsolete
and so I was like I have something to do
I'm just going to do the right thing
because like because I learned all this
stuff from other people right it's not
like I invented right what I was doing
um I mean I had a few novel ideas but
for the most part like I learned all
this from other people so that this was
going on in the world it just wasn't
going on in our world and now it's in
our world like you know but I left this
vacuum when I left and so
all these guys kept coming to me like
when they got when they got out
especially
um and I don't know if you uh do you do
you know anything about the honor the
honor Foundation yeah yeah yeah I mean I
definitely know about it yeah for sure
so Joe Musselman I've spoken there a
couple times yeah so Joe Musselman was
the guy who founded the music I didn't
make it through buds um and uh he wanted
to do this educational component of it
and I'd seen enough Team guys like these
guys need a medical rehab that year too
right so like educate them for a year
but like let's get them in medical shape
first so that they can actually learn so
they can remember they can sleep they
can right uh and so they're not
emotional wrecks and you know react with
anxiety and all this and all this other
stuff and so
um
you we pitched that's how I got back and
involved with
uh Dr Rice a guy who talked to me in
medical school is he had this great
clinic and point limit is huge and he
had very few patients and uh so he had
the clinical space and we were like
should we pitch him like hey man could
we run like this pilot program through
here and we were trying to raise money
for that the money just wasn't there for
the medical because it was too expensive
but we did like I think we did like 10
families like team team got his family
or something proof of concept
um and so and then I would and then I
ended up working at the clinic instead
of just doing my plan was to do that
like to build that
um because all everybody was calling me
anyways all the team guys are calling me
anyway and they still to this day
um like I'm always managing 50 guys
and you're one they trust me to I I know
our community better than anybody and I
know what they need I know what their
problems are before they even know their
problems are
um and so I was
uh like that's kind of been in my
philanthropic work it's just like I just
kept do you do that for civilians as
well I do it for civilians and they pay
me they pay me a lot so that I don't
have to charge the team guys right and
uh up until just recently like I'm I'm
on a bunch of different advisory boards
for
um the non-profits who are trying to
help our guys out
um and so I've never charged any of the
team guys for
uh my time but they have to pay for
their meds because they're not you know
it's not coming through Tricare
um and so now a lot of these foundations
are paying for their meds and so in the
last couple of years like it's it's
gotten a lot better you know
um and there there's even I haven't seen
any but there's other doctors that are
doing this work with these foundations
and they're they're treating some active
duty guys too so and then you ended up
making your your sleep supplement too
yeah so actually when I was when I was
at the
I was at the clinic I was at the
concierge Clinic
um
is life Wellness by the way give him a
shout out maybe like wellness in Point
Loma still I'm still active still still
there yeah life Wellness Institute I
think it's called um
and uh you know so I worked there for a
year and
I mean I just I just had so much there's
so much demand for my time and like
there's no way I could do what I needed
to do
um the team still hadn't caught up they
still weren't doing anything about sleep
um and so the guys were just kind of
haranging me into like dude just make it
a product like how hard is this to do
I'm like all right like I'll so I'm like
I mean step away from the clinic for a
year I'm gonna start the sleep
supplement I'll just live off of my
Consulting
um and I think I was doing an hourly
rate back then I do like annual programs
now but um I I said I'll just live off
of my Consulting I'll start this thing
up and go back and so your Consulting is
is this medical Consulting for
individual humans is that yeah yeah okay
so I mean I do uh like I do some
organizational stuff like no like
um whatever law enforcement or
professional sports team or whatever
they'll hire me to lecture and kind of
help them design a program but you're
talking about like hey I want you to
help me feel better yeah and so here's
my money yeah so now I have now now I do
annual programs people can only do a
year like I won't I don't do multiple
years like I'm going to teach you
everything you need to know in a year
you have to have another doctor because
I'm not I'm not your current security or
whatever yeah you get a cold you have a
broken leg like that's not me so I and
and what I do is performance like I
didn't break I didn't call off that at
the teams but if you think about that's
exactly what it's doing there's
performance right like none of these
guys had a disease they just weren't
performing like they felt like they
should perform
and so
um so that that's what I do now and so
it's mainly like
you know big Executives or entrepreneurs
traded their health for wealth for 20 or
30 years and now they had like a big
exit whatever like you know they sold
their company they got 100 million
dollars they don't care about money they
want to buy that Health they want that
Health back they want to be depending on
athletes again I'm like pump the brake
Sparky like maybe we can get you we can
drop 40 pounds of fat off here in the
year uh and get you back into being able
to be physical and you know yeah so uh
so yeah I I charge those guys a lot of
money one to make sure that they're
motivated and uh to just pay for me to
treat Team guys right and then like
right before I'd say like a year before
I got out I was at a conference where
uh a guy was lecturing on TBI and I had
at least one guy I knew that had TBI
because that's this is what we thought
about tbis in this time
um so you know if somebody hadn't been
knocked unconscious then you didn't
think they had a TBI
um so then I I went to this guy's
lecture and he was working with pugilist
and uh and some NFL guys
and he starts throwing up his case
reports
and like looking at their blood markers
I'm wearing something looks exactly like
my guys are you kidding me
so then I started doing my own research
and in 2009 there was a jam article
written and it was done uh
between Cambridge and Harvard thousands
of people and uh they they have this
Imaging called dtis and it's like it's
so it's so uh
the resolution's so clear they can see a
single neuronal track breaking Bang
and they call that a minor TBI so
they're like What's the threshold
turns out it's a 1.09 G's
they got that from the
1.09 G's can cause a minor TBR a minor
TBI they were getting that from the
acceleration changes on a roller coaster
I'm like
I wonder how much our stuff is so I
started investigating like yeah and this
stuff we've tested like we haven't
tested everything obviously but
um you know that they're like the fat
like damn next fast boats
they average 60 G's
for hours they Peak over 100 G's
so they're just like boom head injury
head injury head injury like every
freaking wave right
um and then I started learning about uh
over pressurization TPI right that's
going to be great and so I don't know
what the threshold is for that but if
something close to that one point
they're allergies right well if if
you're if you're in a concrete room with
three and fours like every round that
comes out is 30 G's
if you're shooting a Carl Gustav the the
the shooter gets 200 G's the Spartacus
like 300 these uh you know the uh you
know hard parachute openings or
two to three G's um yeah being in the
back of a Humvee with a 50 cal going
it's like 60 G's every every round you
know so I'm like well I don't have a guy
who doesn't have thousands of tbis and
this has now been proven
um and if you know Lark and Frank Larkin
and you know his son yeah suicide and he
had his brain analyzed and so when you
look at if you you look at Fighters and
look at NFLs
um NFL guys they have the CT right
you've heard of that and it's like
specific regions of the brain that's
show some specific abnormalities
what happens in the in the over
pressurization is like that pressure
wave goes through your skull right it
goes right through your skull
and then they have it on photography now
like
um I guess that's what a lot of frames
per second or so uh 60 frames per second
or something I can slow that down and
get really wrestling with it so as the
as the wave comes by
just like any other wave it's moving
it's having impact on the material it's
going through
well the different densities move at
different rates
so the lining of your brain the dura
that moves at a different rate than the
vasculature and that moves at a
different rate than the white matter and
that moves at a different rate than the
gray matter and that moves at a
different rate than the little fascicles
that hold the cerebral spine so let's
put it in a blender so you just Shear
everything
and we have and when you do autopsies on
our guys who's suicided their entire
brain is covered with these
towel proteins like the these markers
for damage at every interface so where
where the vasculature meets the brain
where the dura meets the brain where the
white matter meets a gray matter with a
gray matter of reach meets the cerebral
spinal fluid
the entire brain and we don't know what
to do about that
now there's peptides out that we know
help that's going to be the next that's
the next Frontier medicine I believe
that's where I'm spending a lot of my
time uh with our guys now hyperbarics
helps for sure
um hormones obviously help
so
you know that that's
you know that that's what that's what
our guys need but this needs to be done
proactively because you think about it
like over time
the equipment just keeps getting more
and more dynamic
the people inside the equipment are the
same right we're the fragile bit now and
there's got to be like it's different
for different people you know I always
bring up George Foreman and Muhammad Ali
like George Foreman right now he's up
there you know he's totally good to go
right
um and I've known a lot of Fighters
and some Fighters are just like they're
fine right and some guys are not clearly
and it's the same thing with football
like you meet guys that played football
their whole life and then they went out
and they're doing totally normal things
and other guys get totally messed up
from football so there's got to be some
genetic component to it as well right
yeah there's there's genetic variation
to everything right so
and I don't know why anybody's surprised
by this right it's like
um
you know we'd like to say that all men
are created equal it's not true this is
like every people aren't equal and some
people have aptitudes that other people
don't have
um you know it's like this
uh this me this misnomer of the super
sleeper right if you have this Gene
combination then you don't need as much
sleep
it's not true you know what what's true
is that you don't suffer as much as most
people when you don't sleep right when
you shorts when you short sleep you
don't have the same problems as the
average Joe now there's somebody on the
other side of the spectrum too did you
take a few hours of sleep away and
they're completely incapacitated these
are people who don't make it through
hell week these are people who make it
into our community I've always well you
know people always talk about my sleep
and I the genetic component I talk about
because like my oldest daughter
I would be going to bed at 11 o'clock at
night when she was in high school and
she'd be up studying yeah and I'd wake
up at 4 30 in the morning and she'd be
up studying and and so she was just kind
of like me right she didn't need a ton
of sleep
my wife like this girl's going to bed
you know I mean she's going to bed and
like she'll be up later right right my
my middle daughter if there's not an
emergency going on she's in she's she's
gonna get out of bed when she feels like
it like yeah there's not major emergency
going on my son's kind of like
uh he can he can deal without sleep
pretty well and then my youngest
daughter just like my wife so it seems
to me like and you know we all live in
the same house right there's like half
of us get up early and are going to do
something the other half are still in
bed and that's the way it is every day
and it's not because I treated him any
differently yeah I wanted them all to
get up early and some of them just it's
not part of their gig right uh it's not
part of my wife's gig either people say
to me like how do you get up in the
morning like without waking up your wife
my wife ain't waking up unless I start
firing weapons in the bedroom like I'm
good to go that girl is she's out and
she's in her own little La La Land which
is awesome so it seems like there is a
some level of genetic component to it
where and you know this even happened in
the teams like I would I definitely 100
like I wouldn't need to sleep with at
all and guys would be like hey I need to
go down and I'd be like cool yeah go to
sleep and I I could go for a really long
time without you know on very little
sleep and I've always been in like that
right and so there's there's got to be
some level of like and I'm not claiming
to be like oh there's some genetic gift
but there's something where it's like oh
I can get by a little bit less you know
we we can test your genetics and see if
you're on super sleepers I I I wouldn't
be surprised if I was and I wouldn't be
surprised if I wasn't you know I mean
it's super rare it's like yeah the
everybody wants to put themselves in
that category and we're like well I'm
just uh right and I'm not saying that
I'm not I'm not I'm not saying this as
you but um well I just kind of did that
so I guess I'm guilty but no I actually
don't think I really am yeah I don't
think I really am I think I I think you
know I I think the odds of being that is
something like being struck by lightning
while being attacked by a shark all
right I mean it's super super rare but
think about us like anything else like
how much do you suffer from a rock like
you know you can go do whatever 10 20
Mile Road like how much are you gonna
suffer does everybody suffer the same no
no right how much weight can you live
the same as everybody else like if you
train the same like if you like
how many how fast can you read how much
do you retain like everybody's different
than everything how much sleep do people
need eight hours
so like I if if I go to sleep I can't
sleep eight hours like I will not sleep
eight hours and not because you sleep
could have been a 10 30 wake up at 4 30.
like that's kind of normal
seven hours yeah
yeah six hours six hours yeah and
sometimes I go to bed at 10. you know
like they're six and a half hours but
you know if I'm it's hard for me to
sleep like I'll I'll be in some
situation where you know whatever I'm go
my wife and I go stay somewhere or
whatever and we have we there's you know
no uh what is it
um there's nothing to do right we're on
vacation for lack of a better word Echo
Charles we're cruising we're cruising
and like I'll go to bed and it's so
annoying because you know like like then
I'm awake we're in some random place and
my wife's gonna sleep for more four more
hours right now right and I'm like
walking around in circles doing burpees
in my room yeah so yeah it'd be
interesting you know what you know what
else was an interesting sleep experiment
the ARG did you ever do an arc platoon
no so I narrowly avoided you go out on a
ship and when you're out on a ship you
have no job as a seal you have no job
and you're in this weird compartment
where it's just dark if you you know
guys and we had guys I had a guy in one
of my platoons
um he would sleep for days like
seriously and and he was also a guy that
probably had some kind of a sleep
disorder because he would fall asleep on
patrol like we'd we'd be patrolling and
you know take a 10 minute break you know
Patrol for 50 minutes breaks for ten
Patrol for 15 minutes great for ten we'd
be doing a hump across the desert we'd
we'd sit down we say an older guy no no
no
um he lives in Texas I'll introduce you
to him but he uh we'd like take a break
and you know you're like freaking sword
you're humping through the desert
Thursday and all three minutes in the
break you hear like
and he'd be snoring
yeah
he would go on the ship
sometimes he slept for like actual like
like 18 hours you know and then he'd get
up looking all groggy and so on the ship
you could sleep as much as you possibly
could want I mean there's nothing to do
like sub officers yeah same way even if
you're the most like highly disciplined
person and you're trying to complete
your degree and you're learning to play
guitar and you're working out you still
have like an extra 17 hours yeah yeah to
do nothing yeah so but even on the
argument was like I could sleep but I
and I didn't really think about sleep
too much but like I go to sleep and then
just wake up like okay well I'm gonna do
whatever yeah I mean there's several
genes for that I'd I wouldn't be
surprised if you have some of them I I'm
I'm a guy who
can get away with that much sleep as
well
um it's not as true no it's not true now
like the older you get the harder it is
but my freaking old neighbor Vietnam
dude this this dude like I'd wake up in
the morning he'd be sitting out on this
porch yeah he he's like I don't sleep I
don't need to sleep I'm watching the
neighborhood he'd tell me I'd be like
right oh man yeah yeah I mean it it's
there's variation like when when I was
in
I mean obviously the whole time I was in
college and the whole time I was in
medical school like I said I'm married I
have kids you know like I'm coming over
for medical school I'm like making
dinner for my kids you know giving them
baths or eating them just like
deprivation like and I sleep in
five hours a night on a good night for
10 years
now though part of its age but part of
its
and it wasn't until I figured this out
for the team guys that I said well maybe
I should apply this [__] to myself right
so I started sleeping more
and now I now I'm really bad at
functioning without sleep like I got
used to it and I think you kind of the
the thing about sleep like one of the
things that makes
and then obviously I don't just do sleep
but sleep's a big component of what I do
um just because it's the most important
factor of your health
um
if I do my job well first of all the
sales pitch sucks because what is sleep
good for everything what's the worst
thing you can say in marketing is like
it fixes anything like every you're
better at everything when you sleep well
you're smarter you're faster you're
stronger you're smarter you're better
looking like everything everything's
better lower stress hormones higher
anabolic hormones better appetite
regulation everything's better when you
sleep and so that's a terrible sales
pitch now the other thing is like if I
do my job really well and you sleep
amazingly well you won't remember it at
all
and like no trust me it was great for
you and like you know now at least you
have wearables and you have people
tracking their sleep and something like
there's some you know there's something
to make it a little easier for me in
that in that respect but
um like there's I mean there's no
question that's the most important
aspect of your life and the big problem
the other big problem with sleep is that
when you so like the whole point of me
going to sleep tonight
is to repair everything that I did to
myself today right everything that every
fuel source I exhausted that needs to be
replenished or any damage I've done that
needs to be fixed and then I needed
you store things and organize things and
set hormone regulation for tomorrow so
I'm repairing from today and preparing
for tomorrow
well it takes eight hours to recover
from 16 hours
vast majority of the time let's say 95
percent of the people on the planet are
that way 98 of people maybe that way
if I only sleep six hours instead of
eight hours
tomorrow still comes right if I didn't
repair and prepare 100 how do I do
tomorrow right where am I going to get
the energy from well I'm going to get
that from stress hormones that's going
to increase and stress hormones are
catabolic
if you think about it if I went to sleep
and I could repair 100 and prepare 100
for tomorrow I would never age
all right I'd be exactly the same every
day I'd wake up exactly the same every
day there would be no aging involved the
fact that I can't
the reason I age if I decide to cut away
25 of my sleep on purpose I'm choosing
to age 25 faster if I'm somebody who's
capable of sleeping eight hours right
and like you said like not everybody is
and some of that's learned some of
that's yeah it might just be like
habitually right
um and like I I had a 80 well she was in
her late 70s at the time uh client like
probably 10 years ago
and she's like I haven't slept more than
four hours and
20 years
and I was like that's not good for you
so I get her like just sleep hygiene and
just my sleep supplement no drugs no
hormones not like just like nutritional
supplements and sleep hygiene ritual
around sleep started sleeping eight
hours a night
as far as I know she still is you know I
haven't talked in a few years but and
she feel better she just feel like she's
wasting one quarter of her day
so so so here here this this is true
about everything I do so everything
Performance Based so I get people to
sleep I get people to eat right to get
people to exercise riding get people to
control their stress get their hormones
in order or get their inflammation down
with peptides whatever
um and they come to me like oh my God I
didn't realize how bad I was until I
felt good
and that's like a month into her and
then another month later oh no no now I
feel like I used to feel like now and
then so it takes like three or four
months of like really good behavior to
realize how much you've lost because our
awareness like I said our awareness of
sleep isn't there that's the whole idea
of it right we're not paying attention
to that
um but our self-awareness of how
impaired we are just like a drunk person
the research has been done over and over
again
I deprive you of this much sleep I give
you this many alcohol drinks your blood
alcohol level is this you haven't slept
this much same thing like correlates
exactly that I I just like that's so
hard for me to understand it it does
Plateau I like here's an example of this
so we do an event at Echelon front
called the muster and it's a big event
and when we first started doing it
I'll talk about the second one that we
did was in New York City
it's you know there's 900 people coming
there's all this stuff to get done
there's and so long story short we we
behind the scenes we weren't as squared
away as we should have been so we had a
bunch of stuff to do preparing these big
briefs these slides get ready and we had
to do all this stuff and so life who's
doing it with me
I think it was like 1 30 in the morning
and we're the the events the next day
it's 1 30 in the morning we're signing
900 uh
certificates of graduation we're gonna
wake up at 3 30 to go do pt so we're on
stage I mean I'm on stage with two hours
of sleep yeah and I'm answering
questions I'm giving presentations and
that day is like starts at we get up at
3 30 wept we go 4 30. the group comes in
pts we go get up on stage we do all day
same thing the next day the next day we
got other stuff we got to do we get no
sleep and like and bro I mean we're
we're on operations we used to like
going on an operation
especially in ramadi you're planning
you're planning planning planning right
uh I'm saying especially in ramadi for
me because we would plan with the Army
we got to go check in we've got Iraqis
we've got all the stuff going on by the
time we go in the field we haven't slept
right I remember being so happy to go in
the field because I can finally sleep
for like three hours yeah under under a
bush on rocks and Cactus yeah and so
that's great yeah I never and look I
mean I've been drunk before right and I
wouldn't want to I wouldn't trust myself
to get up on stage right and and you
know if I had if I had I think I could
probably have four drinks
and still like present at the monster
it'd be a little bit extra yeah but if
you got me to like six drinks it'd be a
different event right and it wouldn't be
good
uh so this is a little bit kind of an
exaggeration here acutely you can
compensate right so if you think about
um
so you know you have the autonomic
nervous system right you have the
parasympathetic and sympathetic and and
the maximal sympathetic output we call
Fireflight
right so when you get up into fight or
flight
what happened she becomes superhuman
right your pupils dilate you start
taking in a bigger field of vision right
your lungs expand you start taking more
oxygen your blood pressure goes up your
peripheral perfusion goes down so if you
get cut you don't bleed to death you
know your reflexes get faster you
release a bunch of glucose you have more
endurance more strength faster reflexes
like you're super human you feel
you don't feel amazing because you're
scared right but you feel alive and
ready right and you're like so like you
can react to everything faster why don't
you run around like that all the time
because it's catabolic you're using
yourself as the fuel source to get away
from the danger because it doesn't
matter so that's what I do in those
events yeah so it doesn't matter if you
can digest your food it doesn't matter
if you can fight off infection it
doesn't matter because like you need to
get away from this threat yeah before
any of that matter so you're gonna
Marshal 100 of your resources into that
so that's what you're doing you're just
digging into the well or whatever yeah
you're digging in now if you recover
from that yeah and believe me like not a
big deal like we have gone through Great
Lengths like now at the muster it's
everything is just so well oiled I mean
we're going to bed at like you know nine
o'clock at night we joke about it we're
like all right 8 30 I'm getting ready to
go to bed like we we love that you know
it's this this this is to support what
you're talking about I know this 100
percent
if I don't get I actually when I'm going
to uh an event like if I'm gonna speak
I
sleep a little bit less because it makes
me more Hampshire engaged with what's
happening even more emotional like right
I will be more emotionally engaged if
I'm super well rested I'm just kind of
like cool like everything else
everything's good
um and and I'll tell you another thing
that well you already mentioned it like
when I'm if I'm eating like crap yeah
bro my it's a I feel like crap right but
the sleep is crap and that's a disaster
the other thing is when you talk about
stress
I mean
I don't stress about a lot like even
like and I think it's getting you know
you get used to in the teams like what
what you know I wrote about in this book
like what you got to know what to worry
about what's important what's not
important and for me the the list of
things that are important
is this list that has like four things
on it it's like is your fam is my family
healthy right right like okay like
that's something that but hey they're
healthy so I'm not stressed about that I
can't like there's nothing else in the
stress box that I'm really like because
if you know what's going on oh this
product is coming out okay well what if
the product fails okay then we'll do
something yeah like so I think I'm
pretty good with the keeping myself out
of the stress Zone
eating good
um when I eat like crap I feel like crap
uh look and pizza's a you know you gotta
look at some pizza whoever invented that
like what an evil bastard and chocolate
chip cookies all night so like you get
that but
um I'm lucky yet I'm I don't like pizza
I didn't like it until I was like damn
but like my wife meant she made this she
my wife is the best prime rib prime rib
in the world like it's it's the world
class prime rib and somehow she triple
ordered or something over Thanksgiving
because we we eat prime rib for
Thanksgiving but she we thought we were
having people people didn't show up
bubble was we had just massive hunks of
prime rib and probably I did like almost
a carnivore thing yeah for like four or
five days and then and then she cooked
another one
just eating like one big slab of prime
rib a day yeah and I just was like so
good diet and then the Sleep works out
and the and um so so everything matters
right yeah everything matters
you you and I are very similar in that I
don't stress her or anything either and
by and large I think it's because I
don't really remember I don't remember
all the stuff I have to do if I remember
if I could remember all of it I'd be I
might be stressed but you know stress
hormones get a bad rap because
everything to that is negative it's not
negative right with no stress hormones
you die right like stress hormones keep
you alert in proportion to your
environment so if you're doing something
that's really intense you want to be
able to stress right you want stress
hormones because that's got adrenaline
nor adrenaline in it right there that's
amping you up making you feel good that
cortisol is helping us releasing blood
glucose and stuff like it stored
glycogen into into blood glucose so it's
making you feel better it's making you
sharper right like there's some things
just making you sharper now it does
impair the prefrontal cortex a bit which
is like your executive functioning here
so you don't want them to be too high
because like you think about you know if
you're in a fist fight can you remember
your phone number like probably not
right because like your prefrontal
cortex that ain't working like you're
not going to be planning your next trip
or something while you're while you're
in something stressful
um so uh that you know that's one factor
now another factor is
if you sleep really well and if you
don't stress a lot during the day
even if you short sleep
it's not as big of a deal right because
the quality of sleep is keeping your
stress hormones lower like the lowest
your stress hormones ever are is when
you're in deep sleep
and of course they Peak somewhere in the
afternoon like I've heard eleven to one
one to three like I I it seems to be
somewhere around noon to one and most of
the people I I test
um you know that as you know it as that
Peak goes up people are fearing more and
more alert their body temperatures going
on there's all sorts of like good
physiological things going on but people
feel better under more stress hormones
now you can go excessive and it becomes
it becomes negative but just the fact
that you're not somebody who stresses a
lot like one of the one of the biggest
things I do and um and I I can I can
put out a link for your if anyone in
your audience wants to check this out um
it's like a it's a PDF on my website but
I can like do the Lander for we'll do
duck
parsley.com yeah
or something like but people can
download this the most the most powerful
thing I do is seems ridiculous have
people take a piece of notebook paper
and like draw a line straight down the
middle it's like on the left side you're
right to do on the right side it's to
worry so to-do list is as far out as
you're likely to worry about really like
me I I'm kind of I never really got out
of buds I'm kind of like one Evolution
at a time like maybe I'll plan two or
three days ahead like I don't I'm not a
I'm not somebody's gonna be worried
about something a month down the road
but some people are so it was far out as
you're to do
to worry is [__] you don't have any
control over but you know you're going
to worry about it you don't want to
forget to have the opportunity to worry
about it so you put that on the list
and then you know there's some other
stuff about setting alarms and getting
ready and all this stuff but the big
thing is when
when you go to sleep you realize like to
first I have to convince you of this you
have to convince yourself of this that
the best you're ever going to be at
handling that list
is after you slept well right your
exercise is good your nutrition is good
controlling your daily stress the best
you're ever going to be is after you
fully wake up right to maybe an hour
after you work out
after a good night's sleep so there's no
sense in thinking about anything on that
list while you're asleep right because
you're interfering with your goal of
being the best you tomorrow so now from
the time you go to bed till the time
that alarm clock goes off in the morning
you don't ever know what time it is
because it doesn't matter and you're
going to lay in bed and you're gonna
like meditate and breathe and relax if
you're not asleep and then you're going
to sleep when you sleep and if you wake
up you just lay there and meditate
breathe and relax they're like whatever
if your alarm's not going to go for four
hours you'll fall back asleep if your
alarm goes off 30 minutes later
all right you got seven and a half hours
of sleep in 30 minutes of meditation get
after it go right so you kind of have
that built in naturally and and I think
a lot of Team guys do because you
you go through some really stressful
[__] relative to like you get out in the
entrepreneurial world is like
that's kind of stressful but like
if I fail I can just start something
else you know if like something
collapses like it's not really that I
mean I'm not getting shot at I'm not
cold I'm not wet you know
um
it's just a different scene so
um I think that's that's why you're
experiencing what you experience now the
other thing too to remember though is
like
if somebody goes out for a drink right
they meet their buddies at a bar like
yeah you know I'm gonna stop by chat for
a little bit and take off so I'm just
gonna have one drink
because I don't want to drive drunk
right I don't want to be impaired and
then somehow they end up having two well
maybe I'll have another and then by like
the fourth string feel like I'm fine I
can I can drive home like where did that
decision making shift at some point you
lost awareness of your impairment you
became more impaired and you lost your
ability to recognize that you're
impaired sleep deprivation is the same
way so you wake up and you're just like
I feel good because the stress hormones
are making me feel good right
you're impaired though like we just know
like it's unavoided it's just like
putting alcohol in your blood putting
you know putting stress hormones in your
brain
make your prefrontal cortex not as
active now there's a there's a there's a
little bump where it's actually better
right because you're adrenalized you
can't do everything better but there's
some advantages to certain ASP to
certain behaviors but then it goes too
high and it's like it's really impaired
right like you think about somebody
who's super anxious are they good at
anything yeah it's a bummer no they they
can't be good at anything because their
prefrontal cortex is impaired that's
what that's what anxiety really is you
don't trust yourself you don't trust
yourself to make a decision because
you know you have a bad track record of
making good decisions or something and
so you don't trust your ability to do it
and now that stresses you out even more
and so it can be a really a death spiral
for a lot of people because
um like I said if you don't get enough
sleep
then you wake up the next day with more
stress hormones well the absence of
stress hormones is what allows you to
fall asleep so if you're running around
with 20 more stress hormones than you
need
now when you try to go to sleep you're
20 higher than you should be and it
might not be low enough to fall asleep
and the other thing is your stress
hormones are what's waking you up in the
morning cortisol is waking you up so if
you're running 20 higher then you should
be running then you're sort of your
genetic background would have you
running at well
now
you're going to wake up when you hit
that same level that you maybe would
have hit an hour later if you didn't
have this excess stress hormones
let's talk sleep protocol
for optimal sleep protocol
so
um
like I would I was talking about earlier
you just think about
think about humans 200 years ago
right
or maybe go back say a thousand years
hunter gatherers right
um
we aren't we don't see well at night
we're we're crappy Predators anyways
right without weapons we're useless
right we couldn't fight a raccoon right
we're um so we don't see well at night
the sun goes down the blue light
um leaves our eyes we have
nerves in our eyes that sense blue light
they have nothing to do with vision
and then that triggers the changes in
our brain which leads to the Melatonin
being secreted in the melatonin and then
changes a lot of things but one of the
big things happens increases the
snaropeptide Gaba which slows down our
brain we quit interacting with the world
as much and our body temperature goes
down because the sun went down right so
it's dark we can't see we back up into a
corner to be safe because we're prey a
thousand years ago
like maybe we get in a cave whatever we
make a fire now you really can't see
right can't see past the fire so your
world gets secluded you're not
interacting you're not jumping around
you're not climbing you're not lifting
you're not
right maybe telling some stories
whatever and then
about three hours after the sun goes
down you feel like sleeping and you lay
down and you sleep and your body
temperature keeps going down your stress
hormones keep going down at some point
all that
you know starts coming back up your body
temperature kind of hits a maximum low
and then starts it kind of fires a
survival response and you start building
things back up and your cortisol comes
back up and you wake up right around the
time the sun's coming up
you don't wake up because of the song
you just coincidental right like uh
because that's how you're wired like
every and every mammal on this planet
uses the Sun as it's huge want to be
awake I'm going to be asleep
so that's how our ancestors did it
the closest you can get to that right
that's what sleep hygiene is Right
everything you read about sleep hygiene
is that right so blacking out your
windows yeah because you don't one you
don't want the light two you don't want
to know what time it is when you wake up
right
turning down the temperature of your
house taking a shower taking a cold
shower like you know when so you think
about what do you do as a little kid
right
you have a three four-year-old kid
bashing trucks together banging drums
whatever you don't just throw that kid
in a bed and turn the light up and walk
out
they need a ritual they need time to get
ready to go to sleep we study
hunter-gatherers today like they're
still like 30 000 people who've never
experienced electricity I've never
experienced electricity they still live
like our ancestors live they go out they
hunt food hunt and gather food for two
hours a day the rest of the day or
[__] off having sex playing around
whatever like they're the original
Aristocrats you're really good like
that's where we would be if we stayed in
that lifestyle
um so like you take your kid and what do
you do it's like
time for quiet play right like put that
stuff away we're gonna do puzzles or you
know whatever we're gonna do something
more today we're gonna kind of dim light
and that stuff right and then we give
them a bath why
it's going to lower their body
temperature right because you're not
going to give them a 98 degree bath give
them like an 80 degree bath 85 degree
bad then they get out and you powder
them up and you put them in a really
soft glitching right okay so you're not
stimulating their skin and then you put
them in bed
you know make everything soft and
comfortable and warm and cozy and then
you read them a book that they already
know right they can think about
something like Dr Seuss like trans
inducing rhythmic rhyming like this
yeah I do nothing like Junior right and
so the the kids already know what the
story and that's why they want to read
that book it's like they want to be
settled down and you want to distract
yourself
so you can overcome any of that right
you can overcome any of those systems
um now you're still you're still going
to secrete melatonin
but you can you can get past the Gaba
the gabaergic Slowdown of the brain
right so
if you've ever had any experience where
you're like you wake up and you're super
tired you didn't get enough sleep you
were you're regretting whatever you did
last night because you didn't get enough
sleep and so now you'd be like well man
I'm just gonna
go to work today I'm going to do what I
have to do today and then I'm going to
come home and go to bed like six o'clock
and I'm gonna sleep for like 10 hours
and feel great tomorrow and then one of
your friends talk to you and they'll go
and have a beer and then that's a CNS
depression it should make you more tired
right and you start drinking beer and
like
there's
attractive women around there's music
going there's lights so there's whatever
and like you all of a sudden feel really
good energized you don't you don't need
to go to sleep anymore and like and then
you stay up till midnight that night and
then you know you're sucking again the
next day so um so you can you can work
yourself past it so just blocking the
light
say like whatever you wear blue blocking
glasses you generally lights you have
light bulbs in your house that don't
have any blue lights on like that all
that's available you're blacking
everything out maybe you live in my
Candlelight after you know whatever and
you're getting spending three hours
getting ready for bed but you're at your
computer working on some tight deadline
for something for work that's stressful
and you're going to work till 9 59 to go
get in bed at 10. no that's not gonna
work bro so you gotta you gotta you you
have to do something to approximate the
loss of light in your eyes you have to
do something to slow your brain down to
where you're not paying much as much uh
attention to your environment and you
have to drop your body temperature
that I mean that's what it is so that
that PDF I was telling you about that's
really for people who have problems
falling asleep problems going back to
sleep when they wake up
um and so I I have those people set an
alarm clock like an hour before bed and
this is a generally a good idea but like
anything else if you have problems be
super like be fastidious and with this
and like be exact and be you know very
regimented and then once you get
healthy sleep back just like once you
get fit you don't have to do everything
that you had to do to get in good shape
like you just generally adhere to those
principles
so like uh but when you're having
problems like setting an alarm clock an
hour before it's time to go to bed and
then you spend at least that hour
getting ready for bed right even if
ideally you'd be dimming the lights in
your eyes three hours before bed but
there's ideal and there's reality okay
take an hour yeah and so okay so do that
once you get in bed you have your list
right you've convinced yourself that the
best time to handle that list is after
you get a good night's sleep
you get in bed
you have no awareness of the time until
that morning alarm clock goes off
whether you need an alarm clock or not
right
because if you don't have the alarm
clock that's something to worry about oh
here's a Jocko admission if I don't have
an alarm clock
and there's any like if I have to be at
work or yeah I have to do something
and I don't have a long clock I
literally will not sleep yeah I will
just sit there and like you know hey
when I first started traveling and
lecturing a lot I was
petrified I was gonna oversleep and like
not make it to some lecture so even with
a couple of alarms set I'm like oh you
wake up I kept like like every every
night I'm like waking up did my alarm go
off or okay son yeah right and like
that's the thing so I say hey you have a
morning alarm clock even if you think
you don't need it because that's one
thing you're not going to worry about so
you're gonna the last time you're gonna
see your clock is when you get in bed
and until that alarm clock goes off it
doesn't matter because you've already
made yourself the agreement that I'm
gonna be resting relaxing meditating
doing breath work whatever or I'm going
to be sleeping for the next eight hours
that's it I'm not doing anything else
and if some if something on something
popped my mind I go that's on the list
I'm gonna handle that list in the
morning when I'm feeling good right
when I'm prepared now if there's
something that's not on the list
give my permission to turn light on and
write it down now it's on the list right
and then you just lay in bed when you
wake up you don't know what time it is
you have to go to the bathroom go to the
bathroom get back in bed you don't know
what time it is so I have
uh like the little LED red like clock by
my bed that's that's not needed it's not
needed in fact it's counterproductive
counterproductive because then I'm
thinking about what time it is as soon
as you want it as soon as soon as you
know what time it is
you're you have some decisions to make
now right because it's like well I start
doing some Mental Math right like well
I'm not feeling sleepy it's only 1 30
and I so if I fall if I can fall asleep
in the next 30 minutes all right now you
start thinking about stuff like that or
my alarm's gonna go off in 45 minutes
anyways I'm feeling kind of awake and
I'm like I got this stuff to do and I
got that so I might as well just right
and so it's better to just not know and
go hey no I'm gonna I want to be at my
best tomorrow my best is when that alarm
clock goes off and like I said I don't
care how much meditation and breath work
and relaxation you get relative to sleep
do your do your best to get all of that
asleep but if you know an hour of that
meditation and breath work and
relaxation progressive muscle relaxation
whatever you want to do whatever kind of
cools you out whatever lowers your
stress hormones
like I don't I don't care if like that's
restorative like that's
um non-sleeping rest has its benefits as
well and it's helping with all that
stuff
and as I'm sure you've heard at this
point
um
you know sleep regulate your appetite
right so how hungry I am tomorrow
is going to be determined by how well I
sleep today also what I crave the only
animal on this planet that sleep
deprives itself is us
other animals only do it if they're
starving or they're being preyed upon so
if they're being stalked they're only
going to sleep the bare minimum if
they're starving they're going to wake
up earlier go to sleep later so they can
travel further and find some food
so evolutionarily it makes sense that
we're wired the same way so if we're not
sleeping
our brain's like oh
or being stalked or are we starving
which is it right and so I want to eat
novel Foods when I'm starving so I'll
eat anything right like a green and
brown green and orange donut yeah let's
eat that right
um also if I'm starving what I want I
want sugar for my brain like right now
as much glucose as my brain can get this
is my brain's working off of glucose I
don't have an option there uh ketones
can do some of it if you're really
ketotic but it's not it's still a
majority glucose and then if I'm
starving what do I want to store some
fat so I better eat some fat too right
so what so what's a donut
it's fried sugar brand right and so like
I get all the I get the fat and I get
all of the you know and I get all of the
glucose in me so
not only is it regulating how hungry I'm
going to be but what am I going to Crave
and then the worst part is that it
determines what my body does with what I
eat
right so I eat protein carbohydrates and
fats
some of that's going to be stored as
fats some of that's not going to be
absorbed at all and it's going to go out
of waste and some of that's going to be
used as energy
depends on how well I've slept and how
my hormones are balanced and so
you know one one of the big jokes
especially on men is that
you know our the fat that we think of as
being fat right not the not the fatter
on our organs and stuff but like our
subcutaneous fat that has a lot of
aromatase in it the enzyme that converts
testosterone from estrogen and your
brain uses estrogen as
the measurement of how much testosterone
you have so if your estrogen is really
high your brain's like oh that's coming
from testosterone so our testosterone
must be really high too so we don't need
to make as much testosterone now
and now you get more fat and more of
your testosterone becomes estrogen and
like it's this self-defeating spiral it
just keeps getting worse like now you're
getting fatter because your hormones are
low
but you're converting like you have
higher estrogen levels because more fat
means yeah and so now you're uh you know
it's like it's the same thing of having
high stress hormones because you're not
sleeping well now you can't sleep
because you have high stress hormones
and now you now you're not going to get
to sleep so tomorrow you're going to
have even more stretches and so you
can't sleep because you have
too much stress hormones and you have
too much stress hormones because you
can't sleep same thing with estrogen and
intestine like testosterone gets
converted it's like where you're not
making tests as much testosterone
because your estrogen levels are high
which leads to higher estrogen levels
which means lower testosterone level and
that's a self you know defeating itself
propagating downward spiral and so like
all
um all of the all of that stuff's
uh
non-negotiable right that's that's going
to happen no matter how well you eat no
matter how well you control your stress
and and all that other stuff so
um and how much you exercise and the
other thing I tell people all the time
which is not popular at all
is that
if you're sleep deprived
you shouldn't work out
right shouldn't exercise I mean you
should move you should do activity
because there's benefit to that but you
shouldn't exercise with the intent of
getting better at something right to get
stronger faster more coordinarily
because like I said like all that's
happening when you're asleep all of
that's all that repair and actually
getting better at anything is happening
while you're asleep I'm just going to
plead the fifth over here
yeah I was I was gonna ask you that and
I was like I pretty much know what your
aunt's going to be because there's
people that have to make that decision
like am I better off tomorrow okay I
know I got to be at work by eight I know
it's a late night it's one o'clock in
the morning my kid was awake or whatever
it's midnight my kid was awake do I get
up and do the do the workout yeah do I
get an extra hour of sleep which is
better and you're just like sleep all
day sleep is the is the answer to an
extent like if sleep is going to prevent
you from doing anything any type of
activity then you know find a happy
medium on that like go every other day
or split it in half or something like
that because you need the activity
there's there's a lot of benefits
and by activity I mean
you know whatever going on a walk
there's like some zone two type of
cardio doing some movement like you
could do
like whatever you could do like movement
drills or something like that but like I
wouldn't recommend rolling with somebody
intentionally and you know
um and not doing skill work like
actually fighting like I wouldn't do
that if I'm sleep deprived one you're
way more likely to get injured as well
like there's a there's a very very clear
correlation between how many hours you
sleep in your risk of injury
um and it's and it's
it's huge it's substantial it's the
um the difference they was studied on
high school students the difference
between uh five hours you know six hours
of sleep
and nine hours of sleep was like a 300
difference all right so you're of
getting injured of getting injured well
the dudes are spending three more hours
in bed every day of course
well he's getting injured in their sport
so like while they're while they're
doing this work yeah so we need to get
our sleep that's the uh so here's
something that's really interesting for
your guys for your
um when you're working with Fighters
right so you know let's say I'm a great
Grappler and I'm going against a striker
and I want to
and like I have a camp and I'm like
whatever eight weeks to get improve my
boxing or whatever am I striking is and
so
it it so if
if I wanted to teach you something and I
said
that's something you want to do right so
I'm going to teach how to type with your
left hand or something or play it in the
insurance something like that
and I say hey come in for an hour of
training in the morning
okay and at the end of that hour we see
where you're at we see where your skill
level is then once you come back at
seven o'clock tonight I'm going to
retest you
when you come back at seven you're going
to be worse than your left training if
you go home and you go to sleep and you
come back and test you're going to be
better than your left training
because you're actually learning when
you sleep interestingly if I say let me
teach you something this morning I want
you to take a nap today
and then come back and test at seven
you'll come back test better than you
left your training and then when you go
home and go to sleep you're going to get
better again so if somebody could break
their day
and like have a midday nap they could
essentially get two days worth of
training in a day
uh all fighters are doing that all the
time I mean like fight that's what
Fighters do they're like come train go
home sleep come train go home sleep come
train go home and sleep right yeah
that's like and that's and that's like
uh
two days in football too right it's like
a huge huge skill bump during those two
weeks because
all you're doing is sleeping and
practicing like that's it it's like it
just seems like one long day you're just
like I don't know I just left woke up
and went and went went to practice and
slept and woke up I went to practice
because we would like you know because
it's so damn hot where we were like you
know 115 degrees in the summer so
midday they you know sent us home
go eat you fall asleep for two hours or
whatever we need to go back to practice
and but like they weren't doing it for
that reason but
you know a lot of things that once you
know once you start learning the
physiology of things a lot of things
become obvious you know it's like the
sleep deprivation and boot camp the
sleep deprivation like hell week and
buds
that's a strategy like we're one we're
seeing how well you deal with it because
that matters but two we're also looking
for psychiatric disease right because
sleep deprivation
you know
can things come to the surface yeah can
reveal that and we're in that age group
where young men tend to have
their psychotic break if they're going
to be schizophrenic or they're bipolar
or like that's going to be revealed like
in their
teamed mid-20s kind of thing so let's
just make it happen it's also a
brainwashing thing like when they
brainwash anyone that gets brainwashed
with sleep deprivation yeah you're way
more suggestible yeah
um because again your prefrontal cortex
isn't working engine like you can and
you don't have enough energy to like
defend your thoughts
that's really cool China is Great
America sucks yes give me another Donut
oh man awesome
um what else man do we does that get us
caught up to the current day
other than where to where do people find
you yeah uh doc parsley.com you know you
got doc parsley.com you're on Instagram
I'm on Instagram yeah Kirk parsley yeah
at Kirk parsley and you say you're back
on Twitter I think we were talking about
yeah you're back on Twitter yeah I got
reinstated yeah I got reinstated because
you get shut down you got you got um
yeah I was I was like I was like
publishing
or I was like sharing
you know published research about about
what covet covered and you got shut down
mask you know social distancing like
whatever when my Instagram account I
started
really with doing a bunch of videos on
code because it was such such [__]
at the beginning I was just like oh like
everybody knows this too it's not I'm
not brilliant it's like everybody was
any kind of
basic biology understands that natural
immunity is a thing right and it's
better than a vaccine everybody knows
that always that's always been true
we acted like it didn't even exist so
I'm like I'm pointing that out you know
CNN has their death tracker rolling at
the bottom of the screen every day I'm
like if you did that with car wrecks no
one would drive cars either right
because it's like and they never give
the denominator like this many people
died today
how many people usually die
right oh so it's only 20 more right all
right right so you
um so I like I spoke out a bunch against
it surprisingly I didn't get banned by
Instagram
uh but uh Twitter I was just sharing
some like share research and be like
now this suggests that that doesn't work
or this suggests that we're missing that
right
um and uh just one day
nobody said anything never got an email
just one day I just wasn't there and
then I was like huh couldn't get honest
as you you know you've been banned or
blocked whatever the phrasing was
um and then and I had about 10 000
followers or something and then all of a
sudden they're gone like zero zero but
all my posts were still there and I
couldn't access my name in my face I
couldn't do anything with them
um and then uh it was after the
announcement that
that Elon was going to buy Twitter but
just before he actually bought it
and I just
reappeared all of a sudden
just reappeared
I got it I got an email that time it's
like you've been reinstated
oh okay
so that's what they can find and you can
get your seat formula at docparsley.com
if people want to order that yeah we're
going to do docparsity.com Chaka though
okay yeah cool for your audience just uh
and and we'll and I'll put that uh
worksheet online anybody who digs this
stuff
um what else Echo you got any questions
Yeah couple so the by the way Echo is in
full support of everything you say like
this guy rest is at the top of his list
for life I'm telling you right you can't
just he's so he's Hawaiian though right
like yeah and why there's a very good
culture man robust rest culture so
um okay so the down regulating of
receptors is that kind of the whole
explanation for tolerance of any drug
like you know yeah that um so the
technical phrase for that is it's tacky
for Lexus yeah and that's that's really
what that means essentially there's
there's some Nuance to that but that's
an easy way to think about it it's just
um
it doesn't matter
you know it doesn't matter what's in
your blood if it doesn't have a receptor
right so you have you have to have a
place to catch it both of those things
are equal so think of it like a lock and
a key right so like the the keys maybe
what's floating around in your
bloodstream but then the lock is locked
that fits that key is the receptor and
so if you don't have the receptors it
doesn't matter how many keys are
floating around yeah and then different
receptors can bind to like different
stuff right like you know Holly you said
and you mentioned I forget all the all
the names but you know a receptor made
for a very specific thing can a drug can
be developed and be like hey it can bind
to that receptor that's how most
pharmacology is so most pharmacology
well you know most most medicine most
biology is just it's really just
descriptive right we figure out a way to
look to see something or to measure
something and then we go oh this happens
and then that happens and then we
memorize the steps as though we now know
something like all you did is like put
names to [__] that was happening and
memorize it like you you're not but then
they'll put oil okay so this molecule we
know in this molecule binds that it does
this so
we can like cut that out if that's a
problem or we can add some like we can
have something bind that receptor that
will do nothing or we can have something
behind that receptor that does better
than whatever is going to bind it right
and so that's that's really what
pharmacology is mainly about other than
antibiotics which is like a different
category but most most drugs that have
some effect on your physiology that's
how they're doing it
and then is catching up on sleep a thing
yeah so there's you got some sleep you
got to catch up on them sometimes yeah
well no well it actually at first I was
like I heard that it is then I heard
that it isn't and then but then you get
so we're talking about like hey don't
work out when you're sleep deprived but
bro I'll work out sleep deprived
sometimes have a great workout yeah you
asked me to do that the next day bro I'm
dead so I'll never do it so like I feel
like I use I went into the bank a little
bit used some stress hormones banged out
a solid workout yeah you know caught up
on some sleep did my full recovery and
understand I'm good to go yeah
what was your original question is like
catching up on that is that a thing or
am I kind of at a bigger loss because so
what I what I say about it is um
like like the reason the reason that it
takes eight hours to recover from being
awake for 16 hours
is because you're essentially
you're essentially stripping yourself of
resources and you're building up waste
products right so every cell in your
body is like a miniature version of you
what do you do like your wake a certain
portion of the day your sleep certain
portion of the day you take in nutrients
you do work with that nutrients and you
create waste products right and
your cell has to do all of that right
and so your cells are producing waste
products a lot of that stuff isn't
cleared out while you're awake it has to
be cleared out while you're asleep
especially in the brain
so if you don't do that and let's say
it's mildly toxic so it's causing some
inflammation
and then you don't get enough sleep and
especially like you stay up all night
we'll not go you have now you're going
through tomorrow and you're just
building up more waste products and so
that's sort of damaging you I'm not
hugely it's not like it's not gonna you
know cause some sort of noticeable brain
damage but just a slight impairment
right maybe a little inflammation it's
maybe
strips some cells of some nutrients or
something so I say it's like if you
break your leg
and you just walk around on your broken
leg until it heals it's still going to
heal some to some degree at some point
you're just going to become the
functional new you
um now how badly it's broken and how
well it repairs will determine how how
good the new you is but if you break
your leg and you go see a doctor and you
line everything back up and you make
sure that everything's right there and
you put a cast on it and you take the
weight off of it and like now when that
repairs
my Bone's actually stronger but they're
still like a scar tissue in there I can
still do an x-ray and say oh that was
broken there mate that bone might
actually be better than I was but
there's some noticeable changes there's
a noticeable difference in there whereas
you didn't re you didn't repair it as
quickly as you could and maybe there's a
lot of deformity and a lot of problems
it said it's a weak metaphor but it's
the best thing I have so paying back
your sleep debt
does rebalance your hormones rebalance
your inflammatory Cascades your a lot of
your signaling molecules that tell your
other cells what to do until well tell
cells what to do tells cells how to
communicate
all of that stuff can be mended but if
there's some damage done in there to
where like you start you have some
inflammation
you wall off some of the waste products
with the you know with Like A protein
that kind of like encapsulates it then
like that's all damage and so you don't
necessarily recover a hundred percent
but you can recover your function back
but that doesn't mean that you didn't do
maybe a little bit of detention there
yeah interesting see how complex this is
bro bro you better get your rest holy
doc any closing thoughts man
oh man just happy to be here proud to
serve
um
I don't know man there's so there's so
much to talk about but uh
uh you know
for people in there and uh not not not
sleeping well I'd say that's that's the
that's the foundation I think you get
get that get that in place
um
and then that should repair hormones but
if it doesn't like Brooklyn hormones and
then like you and I were talking about
outside of it I think
uh any anybody who has some lingering
issues after that I'd say you know go
find yourself a doctor that does good
peptides that that helps regenerate
helps the changes the cell signaling
changes what the cells do a lot like
hormones do there's a lot of promising
stuff in there you can we can probably
start fixing some in well we can
definitely fix some injuries without
surgery now that used to be surgical
um especially tendons and ligaments and
stuff like that so
um unsolicited advice for your audience
no it's awesome I I know I always uh I
often get a bad rap for being anti-sleep
and I'm certainly not and uh you know
even in the book discipline equals
freedom field manual I wrote like hey
you need sleep you need to get as much
sleep as you need to be performing at
your optimal levels so yeah I'm on board
um so so you know I I say eight hours
because the research bores out into
somewhere around seven and a half hours
plus or minus half an hour so it could
be closer to seven
the only way anybody really knows how
much sleep they need is if they go to
bed at the same time every day wake up
the same time every day without an alarm
clock and they feel good refreshing like
that's the only way to know no and again
that's ideal what's reality like I don't
know there's some there's a bridge in
between those two where we're gonna you
know use gadgets and tricks and
supplements and things like that like to
help bring reality closer to Ideal
but that's the only way you'd really
know and that's and it's not the same
every day like the the thing is to
remember this is biology it's not a it's
not a car it's not we're not tuning a
carburetor like this is biology is messy
it's approximate and you don't you don't
need exactly the same amount of sleep
tonight as you'll need the next night or
the day before it's like if I go run an
ultra marathon today then I probably
like 26 hours in a row sleep if I do
nothing but lay on my couch and watch
television I might get away with six and
a half hours of sleep like it's it's an
approximation and the whole idea
looking at the Pareto distribution like
anything else man it's like 80 of the
time you want to be doing the right
thing and that makes you more resilient
for the 20 of the time when you can't do
the right thing right or when you don't
want to do the right thing and and you
know the trade-off is worth it for you
so uh you know the most important part
is not to be a zealot and the number one
reason people don't sleep well is
because they're worried about not
sleeping well all right because they
hear something like this or I see like
they'll hear me on a on a law
enforcement podcast or something and I
tell them
shift workers die on average 12 to 14
years earlier than their everybody else
because the World Health Organization
classifies shift work as a type 2A
carcinogen which is the same thing as
cigarettes where which means we're
pretty damn sure this causes cancer but
it would be unethical to test that like
we can't do research and cause cancer in
people so it's a type 2A carcinogen
and your risk of heart attack stroke
like everything increases because you're
sleeping against your circadian rhythm
right and so
they hear something like that and now
they're panicked because they're like
well I work shift work I don't want to
die I don't want to die 12 years earlier
uh so what do I do and uh so the number
one reason people don't sleep well is
because they're worried about not
sleeping well
maybe that's one of the reasons I sleep
well like chill out chill out do what I
said like download that worksheet and
you know do what I said get get in bed
like get in bed for eight hours a night
like figure out a way to do that
that's not impossible
I realize that it's not necessarily 100
possible for 100 of people but do the
best you can to do that
and let it be what it is like you'll
help people say oh you can't get a you
can't go to sleep get up and get out of
your bed you don't want to associate
your bed without with not sleeping and
so then go sit in the living room and
read a book or something then come back
and when you feel tired
I don't agree like I have not seen that
work well
um and and I I mean I've been doing this
for I don't know 13 12 13 years now I've
been I've been helping people on this
and that I I don't I don't see any way
around the fact that
if I get up and read I'm not doing
myself any benefit right if I lay in bed
and meditate at least my stress hormones
are lower at least I'm getting some
non-sleep rest now so just lay in bed
and the only reason that you're going to
associate with negative thoughts is if
you're stressed out about not sleeping
so if you're not stressed out you're
just going well I'm just going to
meditate like this now it's just a place
to meditate and sleep and have sex
why not like all those are great things
like just be in there as much as you can
be so I think echo's next tattoo is
going to say get in bed stay in bed
maybe my son he wrote like this
commercial for me I couldn't find anyone
to work in it
to work to act in it because everybody's
like oh like all the team guys are like
oh that's cheap like I don't because it
says like you know I'm a badass or
whatever it's like badasses like me or
something and
um whatever and and then like I can't
afford any sag actor because they like
you gotta pay and have insurance and all
this stuff and so uh never ended up
making it but at the end of it he's like
so what are you waiting for
wake up and get some sleep
but that's like a tagline in the back we
have like t-shirts with that and stuff
it's pretty cool wake up get some sleep
yeah awesome man uh well thanks for
coming down uh also anyone that's
listening to this podcast right now at
this time or if you ever listened to
this podcast before you can thank doc
parsley because if it wasn't for Doc
parsley this podcast wouldn't exist why
is that because doc parsley
introduced me to Peter attia and said
Jocko should go on Tim ferriss's podcast
so that that is literally the one little
pivot in my life where I was like oh you
know I meet Peter and Peter's like yep
tells Tim you should have this guy on
yeah and there it was I went on Tim
ferriss's podcast and Tim Ferriss uh
when we got done recording he looked at
me and said you should have your own
podcast and I was like that that could
be a thing and then
Joe Rogan heard that podcast and invited
me in his podcast immediately and then
in the middle of that podcast he said
you should have your own podcast and so
between those two guys I started this
podcast so well in the kind of two top
podcasters tell you that you should have
a podcast uh yeah it's it's funny
um the first podcast I ever did was Rob
wolf and it was because
he was at my house I think we were doing
a one of the pre or post Retreats uh
maybe not but we're definitely lecturing
at the same event and uh so he was
staying at my house and he all of a
sudden goes oh [__] I'm supposed to be
on a podcast you want to do a podcast
I'm like yeah what's the podcast
and so I get I so we sit down with like
a computer between us and uh and he's uh
and it's like on the armrest or between
the two of us and we just talk in this
computer and like I don't even know what
we're doing like that I'm not the
slightest bit nervous or concerned
because I don't know what the hell we're
going on it's like I'm just talking to
Rob and uh then he he calls me
I know maybe like two weeks later and he
goes here's dude you got to do your own
podcast I'm like why and he's like he's
I'd Ferris on eight weeks ago and your
podcast has more downloads than his
double the podcast downloaded is his and
it's only been up for two weeks and I
was like what's a downline
anyway so uh like he tried to talk me
into doing my own podcast and I'm like I
don't know like what I'm gonna do a
podcast on sleep like that doesn't seem
doesn't seem sustainable like you can't
do 400 episodes on sleep like maybe I
guess maybe you can like I don't know
and that's the only thing anybody knew
me for back then it's like so
um yeah I I think it would be cool
because I'd like to there's lots of
people I'd like to talk to but I don't
have the work ethic in time to do it I
just like like I travel so much like
Adam I'd be scattered like trying to
compress doing 10 in a day or something
like I don't know like it's more work
than people think it's a lot of it's a
lot of work yeah I think people don't
realize what goes into it but
um well like I said if it wasn't for you
introducing me to Peter and then to uh
Tim well well I I think you gotta you
got to give yourself plenty of credit I
mean lots lots of guys have been on this
podcast that are not done with you
you're not done with you done yeah
well but yeah we we knew the we knew the
Joker Legend spread well I appreciated
it man yeah and uh my pleasure yeah
thanks for coming down
um thanks for having me obviously thanks
for your service thanks for uh what you
did in the teams holding the line and uh
you know especially for when you got
done with the teams coming back and
taking care of the teams and the team
guys and thanks for what you're doing
today to continue to take care of them
and take care of other people man
appreciate it yeah definitely it's
definitely my honor like it it truly is
my favorite thing to do if I if I could
just do if I could just work with
SF guys and like I do that all day like
it's
it's fun like in other communities just
like it's
cool it's cool guys to to treat and
they're not [__] entitled little
[__] that are gonna call me every
hour so like like they apologize for
calling me once every three months be
like hey I'm really sorry but
I ran out of meds like six weeks ago
like yeah uh so it's a it's a great
community and like I said it uh you know
the team slowly turned my life around
like they're
there's no way I would have achieved
10 of what I've achieved in my life if I
hadn't gone there first so like I I
there's there's no amount of uh payback
for that it's like all done I'm indebted
to that Organization for the rest of my
life so yeah you and me both man yeah
awesome thanks for coming out bro yeah
thank you
with that Kirk parsley has left the
building Echo probably your most beloved
podcast you've heard we'll say it to my
cup of tea it's your cup of tea talking
about the fact that rest is
important as you have to say yeah but he
was talking when you guys are talking
about the fast twitch slow twitch and
you know how like you're intermediate to
it bro that was like I never categorized
even though I understand I understand
and so I was like like him where
sprinting cool yeah even if I get in
good shape or I'll Sprint all day as
long as I get some rest between those
sets you know kind of a thing but bro
put me on the bike or running or
something bro I feel like I'm suffering
the whole time I still do it and then
even when I'm done if if I'm in normal
shape or whatever if when I'm done I
don't feel super gassed it's just that
I'm suffering so much during the Run
that's how I felt and I wish I should
have looked it up I don't know where to
cover that subject but I remember
reading an article and they had
discovered this new intermediate twitch
muscles and I was like that's me and I
felt like
I felt like so good because it made
sense okay because like I said I was
never winning any Sprints and I was
never winning any
14 mile runs
but on a rucksack we're just like hey
you got to put out for a long period of
time and be a little bit strong yeah I
was good at that grappling is the same
and by the way my grappling my my
physical genetics they're good for a
particular kind of grappling and it's
actually unfortunately for you it's the
kind of grappling that you and I do
right like you have the genetics for a
three minute round or two three minute
rounds or something like this I have
good genetics for 38 minutes yeah you
know well yeah and I would put it this
way yours you're good for 38 minutes
going like putting on yeah putting on
some heat yeah look you're not exploding
through stuff which actually in Jiu
Jitsu you should probably avoid
exploding into and out of stuff unless
for the most seven minute match you know
unless it's seven minutes it was a seven
minute match I'm gonna you know you're
getting the takedown like if you and I
went in a sec if you and I did a
tournament right now yeah a tournament
match 10 minutes would be problematic
for you so we couldn't even go black
belt we'd have to go like blue belt like
five minute or six minute match you
could win with you know yeah you could
win even I would say more like a three
okay three minute match you could win
six minute match probably gonna be here
yeah after that four and a half like
some kind of a takedown maybe even
though the problem with you trying to
get a takedown of me is you you would be
too threatened by the guillotine and
you'd probably not go for it and you'd
probably lose that's true see and now
you're talking and and this is not a
good strategic yes which I I respect is
what I would be doing anyways by the way
yeah so which is a good point actually
so look we're talking about Jiu Jitsu
here right even though before we're
talking about kind of like endurance and
condition or whatever so Jiu Jitsu the
mental part of jujitsu is way more
important than the physical part of it
where like getting excited and like all
these things and what I'm gonna do how
much you know compared to how much I
know what you know about my like all
this stuff like is such a huge Factor so
just keep that in mind so we're just
talking essentially like nuts to nuts if
me in my physical attributes and a given
or will say standard amount of not
Jiu-Jitsu knowledge versus you and your
physical attributes versus the same
amount of fit like knowledge
just the physical attributes
it would be problematic for me anything
after four and a half minutes I would
say that's if we were even on everything
else yeah even on knowledge basically
yeah because we're both about I mean
we're both like 225 yeah and we're both
the same height and so so that's a
pretty good even match but I just know
more than you do yeah but if we took
that away and we were just you against
me with the same brain the same
knowledge you'd be good for a little bit
of time actually I might I could
probably turn up the heat for a good two
two and a half minutes and maybe get the
better
but bro that heaviness and that like
after a while I'm like bro just just
kill me yeah and I could survive two and
a half minutes yeah pretty much with
anything so that makes sense when you're
talking about the rock where like
someone like me would be like rock this
is light
do that for like 10 20 30 minutes bro no
ways bro when I want to take that thing
off yeah like after a few minutes or
whatever but it'll feel light then it'll
get heavy real quick and then you and
then an endurance guy
like I can jog pretty easily even with a
rock even with a rock that's like 75
pounds I can jog like jog it's gonna put
a hurting on some guys that are a little
bit smaller you know or that have so
much endurance muscle yeah so it made
sense man and I'm thinking back to all
my experiences where I'm suffering you
know and again it's not like I can't do
it but I feel like bro these guys
running have to be suffering way less
than yeah he trained for a couple years
and got worse at Triathlon that's crazy
and it's crazy all right but I know
you're like just because we talked about
rest yeah you're a proponent oh yeah one
of the best one of the best at resting
you're probably the best wrestler that
I've ever known bro I used to be you
know the kind where like you can fall
asleep well you know now I'm a little
bit spoiled we're like
if someone has like like if I go to
hotel bed and the pillow's not the right
thickness you know like
come on bro
or the
bed is like kind of like this oh yeah
because you stay in the luxury hotel
it's actually here's here's a like a
little uh thing I feel bad about
sometimes I'll go and do an event for
somebody and they'll put me in you know
the presidential suite right and then
I'll come down in the morning like how
was the room and I'm always like oh it
was great you know but in my mind I
literally do not care at all bro
remember the time and I'm damn sure not
going well you know the pedal pedal
pillow was a little sad or whatever it
is you just said it's too soft no okay
remember the time it was you okay you
went somewhere like and you stayed at I
don't know you didn't have a hotel or
something so you stayed at like Jamie's
rental I don't know so you stayed
somewhere like in someone's like
unoccupied house
and you didn't have any blankets or
anything so you got like a shower curl
oh yeah I wasn't Jamie's unoccupied
house that was yeah okay okay right you
told me that story and this was like
well into your career so it's not like
you were just friends
actually you know there's Jocko live
it's 20 20. just before bro that story
like of course made me laugh but bro I
was suffering with you mentally I was
like oh no pillow like and you're just
battling through it like whatever bro I
couldn't have done it but I would have
canceled the show
a shower curtain and a rug or something
I was like bro no way bro no no way Jack
all right well we're gonna need rest
you're gonna need fuel another component
it's true as they said yeah of uh
physical fitness rest and and get that
fuel exercise rest fuel that's the three
components for getting stronger
sir so chocolate fuel what do we got
kind of everything now yeah we have
pretty much everything
so we'll go discipline that's the energy
drink new paradigm all healthy no not
healthy all healthy no sugar no
preservatives no nothing and tastes good
yeah all upside
also milk that's that's the actual
protein and you need extra protein when
you're trying to build it's hard to get
all the protein you need by the way yeah
for real yeah how much protein do you
think you need oh well you know I I
usually have seven ounces of protein per
lean body per pound of lean ounces damn
bro that's one gram per right that's
like the standard one gram per I know
some people say 0.7 grams per I say one
gram per
pound okay so if you're going Jocko uh
philosophy that's if you weigh 220
yep
220 grams of protein yep you got 30
grams of protein one can of tuna 30. so
you need
how many of those a lot it's freaking a
lot in one day part that's a lot of
protein now if you eat steaks that's
like we have to work it out
like what 50 50 grams protein yeah
so you need four stakes in one day but I
get real you know not all of us can eat
four steaks but when you get these you
roll the Mulk into the equation right
easy money and it tastes good it's like
a dessert it ain't gonna help you with
your mouth apparently that's what the
discipline is for right there
anyway we've got some other stuff for
your joints keep you in the game it's
all good create take on the creatine
train yeah right that was a thing and
then because it's so it's so well
studied that's the cool thing about it
yeah and the cool thing about it now is
they're finding it's not just it's not
just for getting stronger there's all
kinds of there's cognitive benefits
there's health benefits so creatine we
just rolled out with that joint Warfare
super krill
immunity stuff immunity it's kind of
everything you know what I have to
remember how this is a real thing
getting sick when you take a break
remember that kidding yeah huberman if I
was telling huberman or he he mentioned
something
about when your body kind of when your
mind stands down like oh you have a
break now your body's like oh cool we
can get sick now real quick just get you
know and that happens that has happened
to me like legitimately five times in in
the past 20 years where I had okay I've
been going going hard working really
hard and then I finally get a break and
I immediately get sick oh yeah yeah and
so I'm you know cranking the Cold War to
keep that stuff at Bay yeah
anti-inflammatory stuff man is good man
uh jockofuel.com
Wawa vitamin shop the military Commerce
commissaries Hannaford
Dash stores in Maryland wake Fern and
ShopRite Circle K in Florida HEB come on
HEB man you're in Texas there you go
okay Murphy's Southeast
and Meyer in the midwest that's where
you can get this stuff go get stronger
get better get healthier
true Jack review
what else origin boom you did two geez
over there got rash guards got apparel
durable goods is what they called
yeah trained Jiu Jitsu that's my
recommendation yeah oh yeah big time
um also don't forget about the jeans
the belts the boots
don't forget about that kind of stuff
that stuff is like a big deal because
nowadays it's hard to grab get those the
stuff that's made in America but for
real made in America from the from the
dirt yeah from its Inception as a
thought It's Made in America and when
someone thought about it it was in
America yeah it's true so there you go
originusa.com yep also Jocko has a store
it's where you can buy the stuff to wear
to represent on this path discipline
equals freedom
good remember the concept of good are
you going to represent that all day hats
hoodies all that stuff Christmas is
pretty much done yeah at this point you
missed it you missed it it's okay you
didn't miss nothing
chocolate store.com also we got the
shirt Locker which is a subscription
people like this people are representing
hard on the shirt Locker where you know
a little bit different designs always
has to do with the path though always
the designs always have to do with the
bat now for you to understand it's going
to take some some mental work but it's
kind of fun but anyway a lot of people
just reward to it there's a reward to it
it's called The Shirt Locker it's on
jockostore.com is it fair to say that
the shirt Locker shirts can be heavily
layered it's not really heavily heavily
layered yes it is right on awesome uh
subscribe the podcast go to Jocko
underground.com we're recording a couple
of those today 8.18 cents a month that's
what that way we have our own platform
you can see what's going on with
platforms right now they're getting
people getting banned some people not
getting banned people turning from this
turn into that it's it's mayhem out
there yeah so that's why we have our own
platform Jocko underground.com We own it
we totally control it which is nice so
if you can't afford eight dollars and 18
cents a month just email
assistance at jockleunderground.com
we'll take care because we we want I
want you to be free we want to be free
sure yeah we want you to be free so
there you go YouTube channel
psychological warfare flipsidecanvas.com
we got a bunch of books
um check out jockoppublishing.com get
only crying for the living get final
spin
um all the other books I've written get
them Echelon front leadership
consultancy if you need help in your
organization go to echelonfront.com
we have some events coming up Orlando
Florida April three to five
2023 Dallas October 18th through the
20th 2023
FTX Council Battlefield about we did
those Civil War
podcast Civil War excursions
and those things are now selling out so
just if you want to go to Battlefield go
and sign up for Battlefield either come
to Gettysburg and and check it out or
Little Bighorn very awesome events we
have online training platform
called Extreme ownership Academy extreme
ownership.com
this is leadership and life
lessons
that you can learn online so check that
out extreme ownership.com and if you
want to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
gold star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization and if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org also don't forget about Micah
think taking veterans out of the
wilderness
Heroes and horses.org
and if you want to connect with us well
remember you got doc parsley he's on the
interwebs doc parsley.com he's got
Instagram Kirk parsley he's got Twitter
doc parsley
and for us Echo is that Uncle Charles
he's back on Twitter by the way are you
engaging
sparsely okay but yeah I'm like engage
more I think I hope I'm gonna try
Maybe
well anyways I guess it's not really
worth following I coach Charles on
Twitter if he's got that kind of
attitude I'm on Twitter I'm on Facebook
I'm on the Instagram Echo Charles on all
those things too echo's out of control
I'm at Taco willing watch out for the
algorithm
it'll get you
thanks to again to Doc parsley for what
he's doing and what he has done and
thanks to the people out there in
uniform of pushing your body to the
breaking point to protect our great
nation that's what doc was talking about
you do that job whatever you're doing in
uniform and you're you're sacrificing
your body
to protect the country so we thank you
all for what you do everyone in uniform
and the same goes for police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders you heard what doc said about
shift work where you're staying up
opposite hours and every one of those
jobs I just mentioned you all do that
you also sacrifice your bodies to keep
us safe
so thank you for what you all do every
day and everyone else out there
yeah look you gotta push hard
but
you do need to get rest you you do need
to recover that is critical for growth
and for health
that being said just do me a favor don't
lie to yourself
because there's some people are going to
take this and run with it they're going
to make rest the priority of their
existence
and I'm not saying look I'm not saying
don't rest you heard me you're a doc you
heard Echo Charles chiming in
but when it's time to get up get up
and use the day to make yourself tired
so you can sleep well
and the way you make yourself tired is
of course by going out there
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out